Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 261, wo wir uns über ein Thema telefonieren, fast unterhalten wollen, das uns die letzte Zeit beschäftigt hat und das ist das Thema Videotelefonie. Da kann man natürlich sagen Moment mal, das ist doch jetzt alles vorbei. Das brauchen wir doch nicht mehr. Corona gibt es nicht mehr. Es sind Sommerferien und die Sendung dient heute. Also für mein Gefühl so zwei Sachen. Das eine ist, ich sag's mal so die zweite Welle kommt bestimmt oder möglicherweise vielleicht. Also wir brauchen vielleicht nochmal dafür. Wir brauchen generell vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Videokonferenz in unserem Leben. Und das andere ist, es gibt ja wie bei so vielen digitalen Dingen die Unterscheidung zwischen, es gibt große professionelle Angebote von großen Konzernen, die man nutzen kann und die dann Nachteile haben, die man immer hat, wenn man digitale Produkte von großen Konzernen benutzt. Zum Beispiel, dass da Daten anfallen, die irgendwo sind, die da nicht sein sollten und dass man nicht so richtig die Wahl hat, was das alles kann. Und die andere Seite ist dann eben immer, hey, das kann man auch selber auch, dann gibt es auch noch Open Source-Lösungen. Und das haben auch ganz viele Leute gemacht und sich damit beschäftigt. Und wir sind also insofern hinten dran von, dass es jetzt schon tatsächlich relativ lange gemacht wird. Aber das ist auch ein guter Zeitpunkt, um mal zu fragen, wie läuft das denn eigentlich, welche Erfahrungen hat man damit gemacht, was muss man da vielleicht beachten und was hat man rausgefunden, was vielleicht für die, die diese Open Source-Angebote benutzen und denken, hey, das ist ja was Gutes, das wird schon alles gut laufen. Was genau bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn die das benutzen? Welche Verantwortung treten die da ab? Und auch wenn man es betreibt, fallen ja vielleicht möglicherweise auch Dinge an, die man gerne vorher gewusst hätte und das haben Leute ausprobiert. Und solche Menschen sind heute hier. Herzlich willkommen Basisbit, Hallo, Lukas, Hallo und Steini. Ihr habt alle drei in verschiedenen Versionen mit Videokonferenzen zu tun gehabt. Könnt ihr kurz erklären, an welchen Stellen ihr damit tätig wart? Steini, vielleicht kannst du einfach kurz anfangen.
Videokonferencing ist seit spätestens der Corona-Krise das Mittel zur Wahl, um Schülerinnen und Schüler weiter zu unterrichten, die nicht mehr in die Schule gehen konnten. Das kam uns so ein bisschen hohlen in der Situation. Wir haben mit ein paar Leuten Anfang des Jahres oder Ende letzten Jahres auf dem Chaos-Kongress den Verein Cyber4Edo gegründet. Eine Idee, die der Michael Merz und ich schon lange mit uns rumtragen. Einfach, um Schulen zu unterstützen bei der Digitalisierung. Nicht nur, wie kommt digitales Equipment in die Schule, sondern auch, wie lernen Kinder den Umgang damit. Wir machen auch schon ganz lange Chaos macht Schule vom Chaos Computer Club. Das war so die Idee und das haben wir versucht zu etablieren. Und dann kamen die Corona Covid-19-Krise und Schulen mussten schließen und hatten teilweise sogar das Problem, dass sie nicht mal mehr wussten, wie sie ihre Schülerinnen und Schüler erreichen sollen. Und brauchten also ganz schnell händeringend irgendwas, um da weiter zu machen. Und das war der Moment, wo wir für die Schulen unserer Kinder direkt erst mal und dann auch für weitere Schulen Videokonferencing-Lösungen aufgesetzt haben. Und auch drumrum so ein bisschen was damit, die überhaupt wissen, wo sie hin müssen. Es hilft ja nicht, Videokonferencing zu haben und dann weiß keiner, in welchen Raum gehe ich denn jetzt. Und dann haben wir in wochenlanger Arbeit mit dem Kollegium, mit der Schulleitung und den Kindern zusammen das weiter erarbeitet und Konzepte entwickelt, wie man auch ein Stück weit Unterricht macht und wie man das auch sinnvoll einsetzt, ohne dass es Stress gibt, weil plötzlich 25 Kids gleichzeitig die Videos anmachen.
Okay, das beschreiten wir auch noch dann hinterher genauer. Du hast also sagen, jetzt haben wir einen Verein, der sich schon mit dem großen Ganzen schon beschäftigt hat. Lukas, was hast du denn gemacht?
Effektiv das Ganze in sehr kleinem Rahmen. Wir haben bei uns an der Hochschule halt auch das Problem, dass die Vorlesungen nicht vor Ort stattfinden konnten und es musste eine Alternative her. Und das wurden sich natürlich die proprietären Lösungen angeguckt, aber das kann ich nicht so auf mir sitzen lassen. Und dann musste ich da doch mal irgendwie was Offenes aufsetzen. Und das ist jetzt nach und nach gewachsen zu einer großen Video-Vorlesungsplattform, in die alles Mögliche integriert ist.
Okay, du hast das aufgrund... Also es gibt ja zwei große Open-Source-Namen, Big Blue Button und Jitsi. Da können wir nachher noch genau erklären, was das ist. Ist das auch eine von denen? Oder hast du deine ganz eigene Videokonferenz-Software geschrieben?
Nein, also angefangen habe ich mit einem Portal, in das lediglich Videos hochgeladen werden konnten, damit Vorlesungsaufzeichnungen gemacht werden konnten. Und habe nebenbei einen Jitsi aufgesetzt. Und nach und nach sind diese beiden Sachen zusammengewandert. Und mittlerweile landen die Recordings aus Jitsi direkt auf der Plattform. Und Big Blue Button ist auch am Kommen.
Dann haben wir noch Basisbit, was hast du getrieben im Videokonferenzumfeld?
Im März hatten wir natürlich wie diverse andere Vereine auch ein Problem gehabt, dass wir uns plötzlich nicht mehr physikalisch irgendwo treffen durften, in größeren Gruppen.
Kannst du kurz sagen, wir, also wir der Vereine, ist genau wer?
Ach so, das war in dem Fall ein Freizeitverein, ein Kölner Treffen rund um das Fandom My Little Pony. Und das, dann hatten wir eben eine Lösung gesucht und kam dann irgendwann auf Big Blue Button. Ich hatte das mal spontan irgendwie zwei Stunden vor einem Event bei uns aufgesetzt und dann hatten wir das einfach so ins Blaue raus mal probiert. Wir dachten uns, besser als nur Ton ist es bestimmt. Und dann wurde das Ganze angefangen. Kurz Zeit später ist diese Community dann allerdings auf Discord gewechselt, die mittlerweile auch Videochat anbieten. Aber als Open Source Enthusiast dachte ich mir, da dieses Big Blue Button, da will ich mal genauer reingucken. Dann habe ich eine Community gefunden, eine Gruppe namens Zenfcall, die das Ganze kostenfrei, beziehungsweise spendenfinanziert betreiben. Das Ganze hat angefangen mit ein paar Studenten aus Darmstadt, die in der Uni damals Zoom verwendet hatten und nicht wirklich damit einverstanden waren, an irgendwelche, zu dem Zeitpunkt zumindestens sehr lückenhafte Software unter Linux auch zu verwenden. Die haben sich dann auch Alternativen angeguckt, sind dann irgendwann auf Big Blue Button gelandet. Dann ging es darum, das Ganze auch mal skalierend für viele Leute nutzbar zu machen.
Es ist immer gut, ein Nerd an der Nähe zu haben, stellt sich immer wieder raus, weil wenn die Krise kommt, wird einfach mal zwei Stunden vorher Technik aufgesetzt und dann gucken wir mal. Sehr schön. Ich muss mal kurz was schreiben, weil ich hier gerade wieder ein Abo-Problem habe. Was ich jetzt als nächstes fragen wollte war Folgendes. Und zwar, man fragt sich wirklich ein, was daran so schwierig ist, weil es gibt ja schon relativ viel Digitalechnik, die relativ gut funktioniert. Und es gibt bei Open Source ja so einen, naja, wie soll man sagen, den Ruf, den es halt manchmal hat, ist es sieht nicht so schön aus und es funktioniert auch nicht so zuverlässig. Und jetzt war, also über Videokonferenzen gibt es ja ganz viele, ganz viele Klischees, die, hallo, hört man mich? Ist der Sound okay? Dass sowas immer wieder gesagt wird, das gibt es schon bei den großen Anbietern auch. Aber der Erfolg von so jemand wie Zoom, eine professionelle Videokonferencing-Software, die relativ viele Sicherheits- und Datenschutzbedenken vor sich herträgt, war ja vor allen Dingen darum begründet, weil es halt relativ niedrigschwellig funktioniert hatte. Ich würde gerne, dass wir, also dass das eben so schwierig ist, liegt ja auch daran, dass die Technik dahinter halt nicht so trivial ist. Und ich wollte fragen, ob ihr noch mal kurz erklären könnt, warum eigentlich Videokonferenz-Software, also dass Menschen gleichzeitig zu mehreren sich hören und sowohl sehen, also was da überhaupt die technischen Herausforderungen sind. Die eine Vermutung, die ich habe, ist, wenn man Videos mal aufnimmt sozusagen mit einem Gerät, dass das nicht komprimiert, sondern das einfach nur das Video aufnimmt, dann ein Speicherkader abschmeißt, dann sind das halt relativ schnell, relativ viele Gigabyte und dann fragt man sich natürlich, okay, Videochat, Gigabyte, die Internetleitungen in Deutschland sind nicht so dick. Ist das eines der Probleme? Und wenn ja, wie umgeht man das und was ist dann das Problem daran, wie das Problem gelöst ist? Wer kann mir da weiterhelfen? Lukas vielleicht?
Ja, also wo fangen wir an? Das hat viele Probleme. Das eine ist allein die Datenrate. So ein unkomprimiertes Video, sagen wir mal, ein Full HD Signal, also 1920 x 1080 Pixel, 60 Bilder die Sekunde, sind unkomprimiert irgendwas um die 3, 0 Gigabit die Sekunde. So ein Heimanschluss zu Hause hat irgendwie ein 300.000 davon oder so was im Schnitt als Uplink und damit kann das da schon mal gar nicht durchpassen. Das heißt, auch wenn wir da ein bisschen in kleinere Richtungen gehen, haben wir immer noch sehr hohe Datenraten. Das heißt, wir müssen Video auf jeden Fall komprimieren. Video zu komprimieren ist etwas, das braucht ein bisschen Rechenleistung. Das kann zu Verzögerungen führen und je nachdem wie stark man es komprimiert, sieht das Video dann halt auch sehr blockig aus und naja, man muss irgendwo den Sweetspot finden zwischen der Qualität und der verfügbaren Datenrate.
Jetzt wäre mein erster Verdacht, also so was wie so jemand wie YouTube kann das ja ziemlich gut. Also ja, es gibt auch andere Videoplattformen, aber das ist sagen, die alle benutzen. Wer schon mal ein YouTube-Video veröffentlicht hat, wird feststellen, wenn man das hochlegt, ist es nicht gleich sofort verfügbar, sondern das dauert eben eine Weile und da wäre meine Vermutung, das liegt daran, dass die die Komprimierung relativ gut machen, also das relativ gut schaffen, ein fertiges Video so klein wie möglich zu machen, dass es trotzdem noch gut aussieht, aber das braucht dann eben lange Zeit, oder?
Was die als Vorteil haben, ist zum einen, dass sie bei dem Endnutzer vor allem Download-Bitrate nutzen und nicht Upload und die Anschlüsse zu Hause sind in der Regel nicht symmetrisch, das heißt wir können wesentlich schneller runterladen als hochladen. Und können zum Beispiel wunderbar auch von zum Beispiel so einem Anbieter wie Netflix mit 17 MBit die Sekunde einen wunderschönen Film streamen ohne irgendwelche Probleme. In die andere Richtung würde das einfach nicht funktionieren. Das ist die eine Sache. Das andere ist, dass YouTube das Ganze nicht in Echtzeit machen muss. Die können sich so viel Zeit dafür lassen, wie sie wollen. Sie können das auf spezialisierte Hardware auslagern, die genau auf Videotranscoding ausgelegt ist. Und sie haben ganz genau ausgemessen, wie der Codec genutzt werden kann, sodass das Video am Ende noch gut aussieht, die Bitrate aber möglichst niedrig ist. Das sind alles Sachen, die sind in so einer Videokonferenz entweder gar nicht möglich oder nur extrem erschwert möglich auf Kosten von Rechenzeit oder Entwicklungszeit, die noch fehlt.
Und das heißt, ein Teil der Probleme ist dann daran begründet, dass die Technik nicht hinterherkommt, das Video rechtzeitig und gut genug zu codieren? Oder ist das eigentlich sozusagen so, also in der Software, der Prozess so vorgelagert, dass man einfach nimmt, was kommt?
Es ist halt eine Kombination aus allen Aspekten. Es braucht so ein paar Bilder, die es gleichzeitig verarbeitet. Ansonsten kann es schlecht komprimieren. Es muss ab und an mal so einen Gesamtdatensatz noch mal rausjagen, damit, falls irgendwo was verloren gegangen ist, sich wieder alles irgendwie repariert. Und das Ganze, na ja, da es halt relativ viel Rechenzeit braucht, kann es schon mal vorkommen, dass, wenn der Rechner gerade leider noch Windows Update installiert oder sowas, das mal sich ein bisschen verzögert.
Ja, aber was ich fragen wollte, ich frage ja wirklich aus einer sehr leihigen Perspektive. Und zwar, wenn ich eine Videokonferenz-Software programmieren würde, da würde ich sagen, liebe Videokonferenz-Software, guck doch bitte, egal wie gut das Videosignal, das du gerade zustande bekommst ist, halte trotzdem die Verbindung um jeden Preis aufrecht. Also wenn du gerade wenig Bild hinkriegst, weil im Hintergrund der Nutzer jetzt gerade irgendwann noch was ganz anderes aufwendiges machen willst, dann guck trotzdem, dass die Videoverbindung bleibt. Was man aber erlebt ist ja, man wählt sich ein, jetzt gerade in der Live-Sendung, sozusagen im Podcast, da kann ich ja nachher nicht hin, am Live-Sendung war Basisbit gerade weg, in unserer Videokonferenz, die wir auch nebenbei noch zu laufen haben. Liegt das eben auch am Videokodierung, weil man das nicht so trennen kann, wie ich mir das jetzt gerade blauig vorgestellt hab?
Das ist Basisbit, kann das glaube ich beantworten.
Ja, also da fallen mehrere Sachen zusammen. Einerseits ist eben dieses Problem da, dass die Videokodierung, die funktioniert deutlich effizienter, beziehungsweise die Kompromierung funktioniert besser, wenn das ein paar Bilder auf einmal betrachtet und dann sagen kann, okay, ich habe jetzt mein erstes Bild, das übertrage ich komplett und das zweite, dritte, vierte Bild, da übertrage ich zum Beispiel nur die Änderungen. Das sind dann deutlich weniger Daten. Diese Kompromierung macht zum Beispiel YouTube und ähnliche Anbieter, die diese Daten vorberechnen können. Bei Webcam-Live-Streaming möchte man allerdings eine möglichst kleine Latenz. Da hat man vielleicht eins oder zwei Bilder, muss die irgendwie verarbeiten und möchte dann davon direkt möglichst schnell das Ergebnis bei allen anderen Teilnehmern, aber bei einer großen Konferenz kann es natürlich sein, dass man irgendwie dieses eine Bild, dieses eine Frame zu 100 oder 200 anderen Teilnehmern senden muss und da kommt es sehr auf die Architektur der Videosoftware an, wie gut die damit umgehen kann, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel einzelne Frames mal verloren gehen, wenn zum Beispiel gerade der Upload durch einen anderen Haushalt genutzt wird oder einfach gerade zwei, drei Sekunden Paketverlust ist, dann muss die Software das irgendwie ein bisschen ausgleichen.
Ja, aber meine Frage war ja, dass man beobachtet, dass Videokonferenz-Software zwischendurch einfach abstürzt. Und meine Frage war jetzt, kann das, also ist Videokonferenz-Software als Konzept nicht stabil genug, um zu verkraften, dass sie gerade nicht Videokodieren können? Dass also das ganze Ding flöten geht, nur weil das Bild gerade fehlt.
Also die Videokonferenz-Software macht ja quasi genau das, aber es gibt halt ein unteres Limit, wo es halt einfach nicht mehr tiefer geht. Die Videokualität wäre am Ende so schlecht, dass man lieber das Video ausschaltet und eine Animation anzeigt, dass das Video bald wieder da sein könnte oder sowas.
Also das heißt, die Videokonferenz-Software hat so was eingebaut, dass sie nur bis zu einer gewissen Qualität überhaupt mitspielt. Ich frage mich, wie sinnvoll das ist, aber gut, da werden sich die Leute sicherlich Gedanken darüber gemacht haben. Das andere, wo ich mir vorstellen kann und wo ich raten würde, dass das sozusagen ein komplexes Ding, das nicht so einfach ist, dass wir jetzt gerade schon geklärt haben, okay, also große bunte Bilder überhaupt so dünn zu machen, sage ich mal, dass sie durch eine deutsche Internetleitung passen, ist halt nicht trivial. Und dann ist es ja dann auch noch der Fall, dass die nicht nur an einen geht, sondern halt an vier oder fünf oder 100 oder 200, wie gerade gesagt wurde. Wie schwierig ist es denn, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt so erklären kann, dass man als Laie folgen kann, aber wie schwierig ist es denn, diese Kommunikation zwischen den verschiedenen Videokonferenz-Beteiligten aufrechtzuerhalten und ich würde gleich noch hinterher schieben, ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn man das so vortragsmäßig macht, also einer hält einen Vortrag und die anderen gucken nur zu, ist es noch irgendwie so machbar, aber dieses Ding, wo man halt wirklich seine Familienparty in der Videokonferenz verhält, das stelle ich mir schon technisch relativ herausfordernd da Basisbit.
Genau, also da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze, wie man diese Probleme lösen kann, weil leider nicht alle Leute in einem großen Raum stehen, wo dann einfach einer in den Raum ruft und alle hören das. Sondern es gibt verschiedene Ansätze. Einer von den Ansätzen, der einfachste ist, dass quasi ein Teilnehmer jeweils immer zu allen anderen sein eigenes Video schickt. Wenn ich dann fünf Teilnehmer in einer Sitzung zum Beispiel habe und einer hat Webcam eingeschaltet, dann muss dieser eine Teilnehmer an fünf andere sein Video jeweils schicken. Das funktioniert vielleicht, wenn man eins oder zwei oder drei, auf jeden Fall wenige Teilnehmer in der Session hat, dann reicht der Upload vielleicht noch aus. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel 20 oder 30 andere Teilnehmer hat, dann wird bei vielen Internetanschlüssen, vor allem bei so was wie DSL, wo der Upload sehr, sehr gering ist, dafür das dann dazu, dass das nicht mehr ausreicht, dass man mal ebenso diese Bilder in Echtzeit oder möglichst Echtzeit übertragen kann. Die zweite üblicherweise verwendete Idee neben diesem Peer-to-Peer-Ansatz ist die sogenannte MCU-Ansatz. Bei dem wird das Video von den Teilnehmern, die Webcams anhaben, zu einem zentralen Server geschickt. Und der Server rendert alle Bilder zusammen zu einem Bild. Und dieses eine Bild wird an alle Teilnehmer weitergeleitet. Das heißt, jeder Teilnehmer bekommt auch nur ein einziges Video, was er quasi dem Benutzer anzeigen muss. Die dritte Technik ist dann eben das SFU. Dabei geht es darum, möglichst CPU-Ressourcen auf dem Server auch zu sparen. Das ist ein Problem von dieser MCU-Technik. Und der Ansatz bei SFU ist, dass man kontrolliert, je nachdem, welche Videos brauchen die Teilnehmer jetzt überhaupt. Und dann geht das Ganze auch über den Server. Das heißt, der Client, der die Webcam eingeschaltet hat, schickt sein Bild zu diesem einen Server. Und der Server leitet das nach Bedarf und nach Anforderungen auch passend mit Qualität von den Videostreams und so weiter an die Nutzer weiter. Das bietet den Vorteil, dass der Server auch noch tracken kann, wie jetzt zum Beispiel gerade die Verbindung zu den einzelnen Teilnehmern ist. Wenn jemand eine sehr langsame Inhaltverbindung hat oder gerade ein LTE-Funkloch ist, mehr oder weniger, dann bekommt er zum Beispiel nur noch sehr selten ein Videobild.
Und kann man die großen Namen im Videokonferenz-Business dazuordnen, also welche Modelle die machen? Weiß man das von Teams, von Zoom? Weiß man das da?
Ich weiß das jetzt nicht bei allen, aber Zoom zum Beispiel macht so ein bisschen Mischung. Also die verwenden hauptsächlich dieses MCU-Modell, vor allem bei großen Sitzungen, wo dann zum Beispiel 49 Teilnehmer mit Webcommer eingeschaltet dabei sind. Würde man diese 49 Videostreams als 49 weitergeleitete Videostreams an alle Teilnehmer schicken, dann würden schwächer Rechner oder ältere Rechner und Handys nicht damit klarkommen, weil die einfach keine 49 Videostreams gleichzeitig anzeigen können. Und Anbieter wie z.B. Teams und Microsoft, Teams und Cisco, die nutzen auch hauptsächlich SfU, also das, wo dann die Videostreams nur nach Bedarf weitergeleitet werden. Und das Ganze hat aber wieder Vor- und Nachteile. Einerseits braucht man damit dann weniger Serverressourcen, andererseits führt das aber dazu, dass z.B. bei Teams es deutlich schwieriger ist, mit 49 oder mit noch mehr Webcam-Teilnehmern in einer Sitzung zu sein.
Und wie ist das bei BigBlueButton und bei Jitsi? Dass die beiden Open-Source-Lösungen sind, die den großen Bekanntheitsgrad haben?
Also Jitsi macht viel mit SfU und haben dazu noch Erweiterungen, dass sie auch mehrere Video-Qualitäten parallel sich ziehen können. Und zum Beispiel den schwächeren Anbindungen dann ein schlechteres Video-Signal weiterleiten, während die mit guten Anschlüssen das HD-Bild bekommen. Und BigBlueButton, ich bin mir gerade nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber soweit ich das gelesen habe, ist es MCU. Aber ich glaube, Basis-Bild kann da mehr zu sagen.
Genau, BigBlueButton macht so ein bisschen von beidem. BigBlueButton betrachtet das Audio komplett losgelöst vom Videostream. Für Audio wird das MCU gemacht, das heißt, Audio schicken alle Clients an den Server. Der Server mischt das zusammen und schickt nur einen Audio-Stream an alle Endgeräte. Für Video wird allerdings das SfU verwendet, um dort diese Server-CPU-Ressourcen zu sparen. Das soll so ein bisschen die beiden Welten, MCU und SfU, verbinden, jeweils die Vorteile aus beiden Welten.
Obwohl ich dachte, ich hätte das verstanden. Aber andererseits, ich habe die ja privat benutzt. Und bei mir, also meine Privatstatistik, anekdotische Evidenz ist, Jitsi ist eigentlich ganz super, wenn es funktioniert. Aber die Frage, ob es funktioniert, ist nicht so einfach zu beantworten. Und BigBlueButton funktioniert eigentlich immer, braucht aber so viel Rechenleistung, dass ich habe nicht die allerneuesten Rechner hier, dass schon echt sehr, sehr viel Leistung auf meinem eigenen Rechner gefordert wird. Und die, also ich kann zum Beispiel, wenn ich den Rechner, von dem ich jetzt hier das Chaos Radio sende, wenn ich jetzt hier auf dem Rechner auch noch BigBlueButton laufen lassen würde, dann würde nichts mehr gehen, weil einfach das ganze System ausgelastet ist. Und ich frage mich gerade, woran liegt das Basisbit?
Bei BigBlueButton und bei Jitsi werden hauptsächlich die Videocodecs VP8 verwendet. Das ist ein offener Videocodec, der nicht so problematisch ist bezüglich Patenten und so weiter, wie zum Beispiel H264. Allerdings hat H264 zum Beispiel den Vorteil, dass die meisten Endgeräte das mit der Grafikkarte Hardware-encoded dekodieren können. Das braucht dadurch deutlich weniger CPU-Auslastung. Zumindest auf neueren Handys zum Beispiel. Das Ganze hat aber neben den Patenten noch andere Nachteile. Zum Beispiel ist der VP8-Codec besonders gut, wenn man sehr niedrige Video-Bitraten hat. Man kann zum Beispiel seinen eigenen Server so einstellen, dass standardmäßig als Video-Qualität nur 100 Kilobit pro Sekunde verwendet wird. Wenn man jetzt fünf oder sechs Leute oder noch mehr Leute in einer Sitzung hat, dann reicht das für die meisten Anwendungsfälle schon absolut aus. Die Standard-Video-Qualitäten sind allerdings deutlich höher. Da ist dann jeweils für den Serverbetreiber die Aufgabe da, je nach Anwendungsfeld, das Ganze zu optimieren.
Aber das erklärt nicht die Effekte, die ich beobachtet habe.
Zumindest, dass das auf deinem Rechner dann zum Beispiel so langsam ist. Aber bei BigBlueButton könnte das daran liegen, dass vielleicht deutlich mehr Nutzer in den BigBlueButton-Sessions sitzen als in deinen von dir getesteten Jitsi-Sessions. Das ist jetzt meine Vermutung.
Nein, tatsächlich war das ungefähr gleich. Weil es gibt einfach eine kleine Gruppe von Leuten, mit denen ich regelmäßig spreche, und wir haben einfach alle Tools durchprobiert. Das sind die Erfahrungen daraus. Aber Lukas, hat er vielleicht eine Idee?
Also was halt sein kann, Jitsi erlaubt einem halt relativ viele Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten. Und einer davon ist tatsächlich, dass die Clients H264 als Videokollekt bevorzugen sollen. Und es kann natürlich sein, dass das auf der Instanz, auf der du unterwegs bist, aktiv ist, der Browser das benutzt und in deinem Fall das vielleicht auch in der Grafik beschleunigen kann.
Okay, das erklärt sozusagen, warum der Rechner da nicht komplett einfriert. Aber woher kommt diese Jitsi, wo ich auch so sagen, zumindest wenn ich mein Umfeld wahrnehme, nicht der Einzige bin, dass Jitsi sozusagen in der funktioniert ist, überhaupt nicht so Geiles. Und ich habe neulich zum Beispiel gelernt, Firefox und Jitsi nicht so eine gute Idee, obwohl ich nicht genau verstanden habe, warum das so ist.
Big Pro Button ist optimiert, für möglichst auf allen Geräten zu laufen. Dort werden sehr, sehr viele, zum Beispiel Experimentelle oder neue Funktionitäten nicht eingebunden. Sondern da wird mehr Wert darauf gelegt, die Funktionen, die aktuell da sind, ein bisschen runterzumachen. Zumindest seit Anfang Februar diesen Jahres. Jitsi bietet dafür deutlich mehr Funktionen. Und das führt dann auch dazu, dass manche von den Funktionen, zum Beispiel unter Firefox, zu Problemen führen. Wobei auch gerade bei Firefox in den letzten Wochen sehr, sehr viel die Entwickler mit daran gearbeitet haben, für die Bugs im Webbrowser zu fixen.
Okay, so, dann haben wir uns so darüber gesprochen, was es gibt und was es kann und woher möglicherweise aus technisch begründet die Probleme kommen. Jetzt reden wir oder rede ich ja, darf ich heute mit Menschen reden, die selber an dem Betrieb von solchen Servern mitgewirkt haben. Lukas, welche Software und warum, welche ist besser? Frage ich einfach mal ganz platt. Als Betreiber.
Als Betreiber muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, dass Jitsi mir wesentlich besser gefällt.
Weil?
Es ist wesentlich komplexer aufzusetzen, vor allem weil die Dokumentation fehlt. Wenn man aber erstmal drin steckt, ist es relativ übersichtlich, welche Komponenten wie miteinander reden und falls irgendwo ein Problem auftritt, ist es relativ schnell gefunden.
Woran liegt das, weil die Software so gut gebaut ist? Ich war gerade ein bisschen verwirrt, weil du gesagt hast, ich wähle Jitsi, weil es ist sehr komplex aufzusetzen und es gibt keine Dokumentation.
Der Betrieb ist dann einfacher. Das Problem ist, ich fange einfach mal bei BigBoo-Button an, das hat irgendwie alles Mögliche an Funktionen. Audio und Video natürlich drin, Recordings müssen drin sein. Dann haben sie integrierte irgendwie diese Slide-Ansicht, Screen-Sharing und viele weitere Sachen. Und das sind bei BigBoo-Button alles einzelne Software-Komponenten, die noch mit weiterer Software verknüpft werden, in eine große Plattform. Dazu kommt dann noch irgendwie so eine Login über sich, damit man schön seinen Namen eingeben kann. Und das Ganze wird sehr schnell sehr komplex. Aber es ist leicht aufzusetzen, weil es gibt einen Skript, in das tippt man einfach ein, hier diese Domain. Und im nächsten Moment ist es quasi aufgesetzt. Es ist nicht perfekt, aber es läuft. Bei Jitsi hingegen gibt es effektiv drei Server-Komponenten. Das eine ist eine Software, die managt einfach nur alle Konferenzräume. Das andere ist eine Software, die managt, wo die Clients sich aufhalten sollen. Und das dritte ist letztendlich das Stück Software, was wirklich dafür sorgt, dass Video und Audio bei den Leuten ankommen. Das Recording ist komplett losgelöst. Das ist effektiv auch einfach nur ein Webbrowser, der für die Aufnahme gestartet wird. Das heißt, ich habe im Endeffekt diese drei Software-Komponenten, an denen wirklich irgendwas schiefgehen könnte. Und die sind nach meiner Erfahrung auch relativ sauber programmiert, sodass, wenn irgendwo was ist, ich da bisher zumindest immer schnell durchgestiegen bin.
Und, okay, Punkt erstmal. Steini, du bist wieder da?
Ja, ich bin wieder da.
Okay. Lukas hat gerade erzählt, während du weg warst, dass er Jitsi letztlich bequemer zu betreiben, also aus Betreiberperspektive, da ist es sozusagen einfacher, das zu betreiben. Wie ist es bei dir?
Wir haben mit Jitsi angefangen an der Mittel- und Oberstufe. Das war Zufall. Das war das Erste, was wir eingesetzt haben. Das hat so zwei, drei Tage Ärger gemacht, bis wir alles verstanden hatten. Und hatten dann direkt mal 450 Leute da synchron drauf. Zum Glück die meisten ohne Video. Das hat sehr gut funktioniert, auch sehr stabil funktioniert und hat die Situation gerettet. Wir haben dann an der Grundschule als nächstes Big Blue Button ausgerollt. Einfach der Features wegen. Insbesondere der Features wegen, dass klar ist, wer Moderator ist. Das ist bei Jitsi nicht so ganz einfach klar zu haben, wer jetzt die Moderatorenrolle hat. Bei Big Blue Button ist das relativ klar einzustellen. Gerade in der Grundschule, das Kernfeature, über das sich alle Lehrerinnen sehr gefreut haben, ist, dass sie Schüler, die dazwischen quatschen, stummsch halten können. Das möchten die alle in der richtigen Welt auch. Bitte, haben sie gesagt. Und wenn ein Moderator in bei Jitsi rausfliegt, also wer als erstes kommt, hat die Moderatorenrolle. Ich weiß, das kann man auch mühsam anders konfigurieren, haben wir alles nicht gemacht. Wenn man da Default hat, wenn man rausfliegt, kriegt irgendjemand die Moderatorenrolle. Das war der eine Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist, dass bei Jitsi, bei BigBlueButton gibt es diese Präsentation, auf der man malen kann gemeinsam. Das ist natürlich für Grundschule der absolute Burner. Da haben die richtig Spaß dran, dass man da relativ einfach auch YouTube oder sonstige Videos abspielen kann und die Lehrerin kann das dann anhalten, weiterlaufen lassen und so weiter.
Das heißt, wir haben bis jetzt den Trade-off, die Software ist ein bisschen einfacher zu administrieren oder die Software kann mehr Basisbit, wie es bei dir?
Wir hatten einen ganz anderen Ansatz gehabt. Wir haben uns die Software in den Beschreibungen angeguckt, mal geguckt, was andere Leute dazu sagen. Und dann war direkt ziemlich schnell aufgefallen, dass Big Blue Button das Ziel hat, hauptsächlich in der Online-Lehre, also genau das, was die Schulen quasi brauchen, genau dafür da zu sein. Jitsi hat aber eher so das Ziel, eine möglichst einfach zu nutzende Videokonferenz-Software zu sein. Und das zielt nicht so wirklich auf die Online-Lehre ab. Und deswegen sind zum Beispiel die Einstellungen, die Steine eben genannt haben, standardmäßig auch eher für die Online-Lehre optimiert beim Big Blue Button. Das macht es besonders in größeren Gruppen dann einfacher, weil du zum Beispiel nicht jeden als Moderator da drin hast, sondern zum Beispiel nur einen Moderator. Und der kann die anderen Leute dann zum Beispiel stumpf halten, wenn jemand vergessen hat, sich selber stumpf zu schalten. Aber generell...
Es gibt auch so Dinge, dass man einstellen kann, dass wenn alle Videos haben, nur Moderator, dann auch diese Videos sehen, die Kinder sich also untereinander nicht sehen. Was unheimlich Ruhe reinbringt, kann man sich vorstellen, erste, zweite, dritte Klasse, was machen die alle Videos an? Und dann geht es los mit Zunge rausstrecken, Creme-Massen schneiden etc. Das finden die wahnsinnig witzig. Ich habe das auch beobachtet bei meiner Tochter, die ist in der vierten Klasse, da ist das schon ein bisschen besser. Aber im Großen und Ganzen gibt es einfach für so etwas mehr Features.
Ich würde sagen, über die pädagogischen Herausforderungen von Videokonferenzen später noch zu sprechen. Erne, gerne noch bei der Technik bleiben. Abbasis, du wolltest noch was sagen.
Genau, ich hatte eben gesagt, dass ich online recherchiert habe, geguckt habe, was andere sagen. Da war mir ziemlich schnell aufgefallen, dass es sehr viele Aussagen gab in die Richtung von Jitsi macht Videokonferenzen gut, aber das ist nicht gut skaliert. Und dass dieses Skalieren angeblich bei BigBlueButton deutlich besser sein soll. Mittlerweile habe ich da gelernt, dass das nicht wirklich der Fall ist, sondern dass diese Aussagen einfach nur daran liegen, dass die Mindestanforderungen, die auf den Webseiten genannt sind, bei Jitsi wirklich als absolut minimale sind und bei BigBlueButton sind das eher so die empfohlenen Sachen. Das heißt, die sind bei BigBlueButton einfach deutlich höher in der Empfehlung.
Das heißt, die sind gleich davon ausgegangen, dass werden ein paar mehr Leute nutzen. Das macht sinnvoll, dann in ordentlicher Rechnung zu stehen zu haben. Das wäre übrigens genau meine nächste Frage, weil ich bin jetzt hier wieder als der interessierte Typ, der aber keine Ahnung hat, weil nämlich alle sagen, und das passiert einem auf Twitter ja tatsächlich, man sagt so, hier, ich bin jetzt gerade in diesem Microsoft Teams, das ist alles ganz fürchterlich oder ich wurde zu Zoom gezwungen und ich will eigentlich gar nicht. Da kommt irgendwann der Kommentar, ja, dann setz dir doch einfach eine Jitsi Instanz auf. Und dann denke ich so, also im Prinzip ja, aber ich hab also noch weniger Ahnung als sonst. Und das ist halt eben auch keine Software, die man sich mal eben bei seinem Webposter klicken kann. Mittlerweile gibt es ja sowas für WordPress, dass man seinem eigenen Webposter sagen kann, bitte installier das für mich. Und weil wir jetzt schon darüber gesprochen haben, dass das ja technisch eigentlich eine ganz schön herausfordernde Sache ist, frage ich mich, braucht man nicht auch eine richtig dicke Kiste, die in irgendeinem Netzwerk-Center steht, um überhaupt Videokonferenz-Server selber aufsetzen zu können, Lucas?
Und nein.
Es kommt darauf an, würden Juristen sagen.
Die Sache ist zum Beispiel Jitsi mit der kompletten SFU-Technologie braucht relativ wenig Ressourcen. Was aber auf jeden Fall da sein muss, ist halt die Bandbreite. Die fehlt halt zu Hause. Das heißt zu sagen, okay, stell mir einfach das neben meine Fritzbox und leite einen Port weiter. Das kann nicht funktionieren, einfach weil die Bandbreite fehlt. Es kann aber für kleinere Gruppen schon funktionieren, sich irgendwo einen kleinen V-Server für ein paar Euro im Monat anzumieten. Und da kann man schon die ersten Videokonferenzen darüber laufen lassen. Wenn man mehr hat, wird es langsam kritisch. Da kommen so Sachen ins Spiel wie Context-Switches der CPU, die in Echtzeit laufen müssen auf der Hardware. Aber das ist jetzt zu kompliziert.
Ich will mal kurz sagen, für die Interessierten nicht Profis. Man muss bei Hosting unterscheiden zwischen, ich habe tatsächlich irgendwo einen ganz regulären Computer in einem so großen Schrank, einem Rack, stecken. Der ist dann ans Internet angeschlossen. Auch das ein bisschen komplizierter, aber im Prinzip. Oder das, was ich habe, also das, was ich als Webhosting habe, ist im Prinzip auf einem Computer, den ich mit vielen anderen Menschen teile, eine sogenannte virtuelle Maschine, die natürlich viel weniger Rechenkraft zur Verfügung hat und eben nicht so eine Dinge machen kann, wie direkt auf Hardware zugreifen. Es gibt dann noch dieses Sonderding, womit Amazon sozusagen ganz erfolgreich geworden ist, dieses Cloud-Computing, wo man quasi virtuelle Maschinen bietet. Aber das ist dann noch mal eine Runde komplizierter, hat zumindest die große Rechenkraft. Aber Basis bitte noch etwas dazu sagen.
Genau, ein großer Unterschied gerade bei den virtuellen Maschinen ist dann auch noch, ob man garantierte Ressourcen, wie zum Beispiel einzelne CPU-Kerne hat, oder ob man sich diese CPU-Kerne mit anderen Leuten teilt. Wenn dann gerade viele von den anderen Leuten, die auch noch auf dem Server sind, zum Beispiel die CPU nutzen, dann kannst du mal Pech haben, dass mitten in der Videokonferenz, obwohl es eben noch super funktioniert hat, dann plötzlich nur noch sehr wenig CPU-Ressourcen da sind und die Session nicht mehr nutzbar ist. Wenn man sich zumindest dedizierte Hardware dazu bucht, auch bei virtuellen Maschinen, dann läuft das Ganze deutlich zuverlässiger. Das führt dann auch dazu, dass wir genau aus diesem Grund immer empfehlen, dass man sich keine V-Server irgendwo mieten kann, es sei denn, es steht explizit dran, dass man dedizierte Kerne hat. Oder noch besser sind dann echte Server, die sogenannten Bare-Metal-Server, wo man dann echte Hardware irgendwo stehen hat, die nur für das eigene da ist.
Das ist entsprechend teurer.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade fragen, weil Lukas gerade gesagt hat, wenn man so eine kleine Gruppe ist, geht das schon. Wir reden jetzt noch nicht davon, ich will das für andere Leute anbieten, sondern es gibt ja auch genug Menschen, die diesen Bastelimpuls haben. Wir sind eine Rollenspielgruppe von sechs Leuten, die sich regelmäßig zum Videochat treffen wollen. Wir haben einfach Bock, selber auszubilden, wie man das machen kann. Was sind da die technischen Anforderungen? Wenn ich eine Glasfaserleitung hab, gibt es ja vereinzelt in Deutschland schon. Kann ich damit das schon probieren? Oder wenn ich mir diese Technologie, die ihr gerade gesagt habt, in welcher Preisklasse spielt sich denn sowas ab?
Ja, also ganz grob zusammen, wir haben erste Experimente gemacht, tatsächlich mit Virtual Hosts, die nicht gepinnte CPU, also reservierte Hardware hatten. Da ist tatsächlich, je nach Auslastung der Gesamtsituation, dann auch bei 3, 4, 5 Leuten mal schon ruckelig. Das kann auch mit 30 gut gehen, das haben wir auch schon. Das hängt dann wirklich von der Situation ab, wohin gegen meiner aktuellen Erfahrung der Unterschied zwischen dedizierter Hardware, also einem echten Blech, und der zugewiesenen Ressource nicht mehr sehr groß ist. Obwohl der Kostenunterschied doch noch so groß ist. Das Optimum stellt derzeit wahrscheinlich garantierte Ressourcen dar. Es gibt immer nur so Richtwerte, wenn man irgendwas in einer Größenordnung bis 200 User selbst betreiben will, dann geht sowas irgendwo zwischen 20 und 50 Euro im Monat, schätze ich mal. Das ist relevant Geld dafür, dass man es dann nur ab und an braucht. Man kann die jetzt natürlich, wenn man so will, könnte man die je nachdem, was das für ein Hostingprovider ist, bei Bedarf hoch und wieder runterfahren. Ich weiß nicht, die müsste man dann aber jedes Mal neu installieren, weil es ja garantierte Ressourcen sind. Das heißt, die hast du auch gemietet, wenn das Ding gerade nicht läuft. Und dann müsste man es jedes Mal neu installieren, wieder wegräumen. Das geht jetzt auch inzwischen relativ schnell. Das kann man voll automatisieren, aber es dauert dann doch eine halbe, dreiviertel Stunde, bis der Server wieder da ist.
Genau, das, was da eben als Preisunterschied gesagt wurde, das ist sehr abhängig davon, wie groß man das Ganze betreibt. Wenn man das wirklich nicht nur für mal 100 Leute oder so betreibt, sondern zum Beispiel für größere Schulen und so weiter und das Ganze auch über mehrere Monate betreibt, dann ist da eigentlich quasi kein Preisunterschied mehr zwischen dedizierter Hardware, die man zum Beispiel für 46 Euro für einen aktuellen Sechs-Kerner bei Hetzner jetzt nur als Beispiel bekommt, oder ob man sich stattdessen für 45 Euro eine Sechs-Kern-Maschine bei Hetzner in der Cloud virtuell mietet. Also je größer man das Ganze betreibt, desto eher lohnt es sich da, auf dedizierte Server zu gehen, was dann auch noch mal das Ganze bezüglich Netzwerkanbindung entschärft, weil man sich keine Netzwerkkarte mit anderen Teilnehmern irgendwie teilt.
Der Vorteil an der Cloud ist halt irgendwie, dass man natürlich sagen kann, okay, ich hab hier irgendwie ein Event mit 300 Leuten oder sowas. Das findet einmal im Monat statt. Und dann kann man halt seine Server genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt starten und zahlt dann halt auch nur diesen einen Tag an Rechenzeit und Bandbreite und hat nicht das Problem, dass man irgendwie über mehrere Monate hinweg die Serverkosten tragen muss.
Da muss man ein bisschen genauer werden, dass man einfach nur starten kann man sie nicht. Also wenn das reservierte Ressourcen sind, dann kosten die auch, wenn das Gerät ausgeschaltet ist, weil die könnten ja gebraucht werden. Die kosten nur dann nicht, wenn du sie auch gelöscht hast beim Hosting Provider. Das geht dann nur dann, wenn du auch, sagen wir mal, Ansible Skripte, also Rollen hast oder so, die das komplett vollautomatisch installieren und konfigurieren. Weil du kannst sie dann nicht eben schnell, man könnte sie vielleicht irgendwo wegsaveen und dann wieder hin kopieren. Das weiß ich nicht genau, aber das ist gerade bei der reservierten Ressourcen ist das nicht trivial. Man kann nicht sagen, sie sind aus und dann kosten sie nicht. Und dann schalte ich sie ein und dann kosten sie. So ist es nicht.
Aber das ist ja schon dann der Profi-Ansatz, sozusagen. Mich hat ja eigentlich auch das Kleine interessiert. Also ich hab ja, wie gesagt, meinen Freundeskreis, der sich regelmäßig mal zum Videochat... Ich bin jetzt gerade noch bei 20 Euro im Monat. Geht es noch eine Nummer kleiner irgendwie, Lukas?
Ja, also ich hab irgendwie teilweise schon mal vorher zum Testen mit Freunden einfach so 5 Euro V-Server mir genommen, also 5 Euro im Monat. Und irgendwie bisher ist da nie was schiefgegangen mit 5, 6 Leuten. Und solange man nicht wirklich 100%ig darauf angewiesen ist, dass das Ganze läuft, weil es irgendeine Veranstaltung ist, die vielleicht noch gestreamt wird oder sowas, dann ist das halt auch vertretbar für das Geld, finde ich.
Und dann kann man es also zum Basteln nehmen.
Genau.
Die andere Frage ist das Aufsetzen einer solchen Software. Es gibt mittlerweile Open Source-Software, die sollte man für kritische Systeme nicht machen, aber wo man sich einfach ersuchen kann im Internet, wie ist denn deine Installationanleitung? Und dann schreibt man im Prinzip, oder copy-pastet ein paar Zeilen, die die Kommandos hat, dann geht das relativ von alleine. Oder wie gesagt, am Ende gibt es schon Web-Poster, die auch per-Click-Software zu installieren anbieten. Wie ist das denn bei Jitsi und BigBlueButton? Geht das da auch, dass es so Anleitungen gibt, die höchstens eine A4-Seite lang sind, und dann läuft das ganze Ding? Oder ist das schon noch so, da muss ich meine Robe anziehen und dann erstmal ein kleines Obstopfer dem Gott der Technologie bringen und selbst dann ist noch nicht so ganz klar, ob nach einer eindeutigen Installation das funktioniert, weil ich da schon auch richtig tief unter die Motorhaube gucken muss?
Also das Einfachste ist zum Beispiel bei BigBlueButton, da gibt es einen Skript, das wirft man auf eine Kiste mit der richtigen Ubuntu-Version und lässt es einfach laufen und es wirft einem am Ende noch so einen Schlüssel raus, Das ist das, was man noch braucht für einen Login-Dialog. Und selbst den kann man automatisiert installieren lassen. Das heißt, theoretisch mit einem Skript, bei dem man sich einmal kurz die Parameter durchgelesen hat, in fünf Minuten ist das Ding aufgesetzt. Es ist nicht perfekt, aber es läuft.
Okay, also das kann man zum Basteln machen. Und wenn man es dann richtig, richtig in Einführungszeichen machen will, also zum Beispiel an der Schule, können wir gleich nochmal genau drüber reden. Aber was ist bitte?
Genau, sobald man das mal ein bisschen professioneller betreiben möchte, dann hat man natürlich auch gewisse gesetzliche Vorgaben. Man muss zum Beispiel die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung einhalten. Man muss sich anschauen, was mache ich denn überhaupt mit den Daten? Wo logge ich Daten? Wer hat denn jetzt die Daten?
Ich will auf die rechtliche Perspektive noch zu sprechen kommen. Momentan erst einmal die technische Umsetzung. Und dann meinte ich professionell im Sinne von, wenn ich es für mich mache, den 5er V-Server, da klatsche ich das Ding mal per Skript hoch. Klar, aber wenn ich es jetzt für Gruppen anbiete, dann, wir reden über die rechtliche Seite gleich noch und die Datenschutzseite, aber dann will ich ja sozusagen eher genauer auch verstehen können, was die Software kann. Dann will ich vielleicht mehr Bescheid wissen. Das ist eher die Frage, wie gut, wie komfortabel das dann ist.
Also die Standardsachen bekommt man über diese fertigen Skripts quasi in einer halben Stunde oder weniger aufgesetzt. Dann hat man ein System, was gewisse Standardeinstellungen hat, die einem eventuell nicht passen. Da gehört dann natürlich dazu, dass man sich mal Dokumentationen durchliest, die zumindest bei BigBlueButton in großer Menge vorhanden ist, auch wenn sie ein bisschen verstreut ist. Und beim Durchlesen dieser Dokumentation sieht man zumindest bei BigBlueButton, dass es da gefühlt zehntausende verschiedene Konfigurationsdateien gibt, wo man aber auch ungefähr alles einstellen kann. Bei Jitsi ist das meines Wissens nach deutlich einfacher, weil man eben nur diese, wie eben genannten, drei oder vier Komponenten hat und sich nicht ganz so viel die Konfigurationsdateien zusammensuchen muss. Dafür muss man bei Jitsi aber ein bisschen mehr wissen, was man tut oder eben eventuell auch mal in GitHub-Issues oder in Foren sich die Sachen zusammensuchen.
Okay, ich fasse mal zusammen, das ist Arbeit, oder Lukas, wozu?
Also grob zusammengefasst hier meine Zusammenfassung der Jitsi-Dokumentation. This page intentionally left blank. Also es gibt ein Stück Dokumentation, das ist aber bei weitem nicht vollständig. Es fehlen sehr, sehr wichtige Sachen, vor allem für größere Installationen. Es gibt irgendwie ein auf Docker basiertes Setup, das kann man sich installieren, das hat aber auch irgendwie teilweise nicht ganz perfekte Einstellungen und es ist schwierig darin, Sachen zu ändern. Und wenn man das alles richtig aufsetzen will, dann muss man sich halt durchaus in diese Software ein bisschen einarbeiten, um zu verstehen, wie diese Komponenten miteinander sprechen und was diese Konfig-Optionen überhaupt tun.
Okay, jetzt hat mir Dani Mors im Chaosradio-Team gerade noch in den Videokonferenz-Chat dieser Sendung geschrieben. Nutt slash Stun. Was heißt das? Warum ist das gefährlich? Wer möchte?
Gar nicht gefährlich. Also Nutt ist erstmal Network Access Translation. Da geht es darum, dass wenn der Server eine quasi interne IP-Adresse hat und gar nicht eine IP-Adresse aus dem externen Netz, also aus dem richtigen Internet, sondern dazwischen noch ein Router steht, der ja selber noch eine IP-Adresse hat, dann kann das knifflig werden. Nicht, dass das nicht geht. Basisbit hat das neulich auch bei uns hingekriegt, als da über alle Maßen geholfen hat, dass wir eine sehr große Veranstaltung hingekriegt haben. Aber schön ist das nicht, haben wir gelernt. Und das Problem ist dann, das ist bei den Klienten, also bei den Usern natürlich auch so, wenn die in einem Zuhause-Netz sind, hinter so einem Router, dann sieht der Big Blue Button oder das Jitsi ja nur die externe IP-Adresse und nicht die Adresse des eigentlichen Hosts. Und das kann schwierig werden, weil der Datentransfer über UDP, also nicht über eine kontrollierte Verbindung mit Ping Pong, sondern da werden einfach Daten rausgestreamt und so weiter. Und dann weiß der Server nicht, wohin er die zurückstreamen soll.
Ich will kurz ein Bild, dass ein Vergleich zu dem bestimmt hinkommt, aber es ist im Prinzip so, du willst, dass jemand eine Information in einem Mietshaus sehr schnell erreicht, aber jedes Mal, wenn du die Informationen abgeben willst, weißt du im Prinzip nur, okay, der wohnt in diesem Haus, aber nicht in welcher Wohnung.
Ja, genau, so könnte man sich das vorstellen. Und jetzt wird es noch dover, weil wenn dann SystemadministratorInnen dieses UDP auch noch abgeschaltet haben, also rauskonfigurieren, dann gibt es ein Problem, dann kann nämlich der auch über das UDP nicht mehr den Server erreichen. Und dafür kommt dann das S, TAN und TURN-Protokoll. Das sind zwei verschiedene Verfahren, mit denen man sozusagen dann relaymäßig das Außen fragen kann, sag mal, als was siehst du mich von draußen? Und dann wird so was getan wie, ich fasse das mal ganz leihenhaft zusammen, dass so was wie UDP über TCP, also über diese kontrollierte Verbindung simuliert wird. Das ist dann schlechter, dauert alles viel länger, aber geht wenigstens.
Warte mal, also für mich ist jemand, der das noch weniger versteht als du. Das ist also Hexenwerk.
Das ist, naja, das ist, jede fortgeschrittene Technologie wird als Magie erscheinen.
BassSpit, wollte dazu noch was sagen?
Genau, also vielleicht wäre es da ganz gut, wenn man sich mal generell das anguckt. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie www.cyber.de oder was auch immer öffne, dann geht das Ganze normalerweise über TCP-Protokoll und das über zum Beispiel Port 80 oder 443. Diese Ports müssen dann auf dem Server geöffnet sein und dann kann mein Rechner quasi, auch wenn der in einem anderen Netzwerk bei sich zu Hause steht, ganz normal über seinen Internetrouter gehen die Daten an diesen Server und der Server guckt dann, hier ist die Webseite, gibt die zurück und gibt das an den Router weiter. Der Router guckt, okay, die Support, wo hatte ich den verwendet? Und dann kommen die Daten wieder am Rechner an. Also einmal zusammengefasst.
Ich fürchte, wir versteigen uns jetzt in Erklärungen, die immer komplizierter werden, ohne dass jemand folgen kann, der eh keine Ahnung von der Materie hat. Die Frage, die ich eigentlich beantwortet haben wollte und die ich deswegen noch mal stelle, ist ja eher sozusagen, es gibt also, die Danimo hier reingeworfen hat, es gibt also dieses zusätzliche Problem und die Frage ist, muss man dann nur die richtige Einstellung irgendwo sich auf einer Internetseite nachschlagen und dann da eintragen? Oder ist das komplizierter, weil man da wirklich selber Dinge von Hand schrauben muss, Lukas?
Also die, um deine Vereinfachung da mal ins Bild zu holen, es dunn wäre zum Beispiel jemand, der an der Eingangstür steht und den du fragen kannst, wo wohnt denn dieser Bewohner? Und dann kannst du ihm dein Paket wunderbar zustellen und es ist auch kein Sicherheitspersonal, was dich irgendwie aufhalten möchte. Falls es dich aber doch aufhält, dann musst du das vielleicht anders machen. Und dann gibt es das Turnprotokoll. Da gehst du zu jemandem hin, gibst ihm das Paket und sagst, ich würde das gerne in dieses Wohnhaus an diese Person zustellen. Dann nimmt er ein größeres Paket, packt das da rein, macht ein Label drauf mit der Adresse des Wohnhauses und der Adresse der Person und gibt das an der Pforte ab, damit es zugestellt werden kann.
Aber nochmal die Frage, ist das etwas, das man einmal einrichtet und dann ist es gut, man muss es noch wissen, oder ist das etwas, wo man immer wieder Probleme damit hat?
Damit wir als Betreiber sicherstellen können, dass so Menschen, die hinter solchen Firewalls oder Routern sitzen, die sehr streng administriert sind, müssen wir extra Server installieren, die genau diese Rolle erfüllen, die diesen Gatekeeper klarmachen, diesen Service sozusagen, dem auch diese Netze noch wieder vertrauen, weil sie sich an bestimmte Standards halten, an die sich so ein Big Blue Button oder Jitsi einfach aus Performancegründen normalerweise nicht halten will. Wir setzen dann so einen Server auf und wenn der richtig konfiguriert ist, dann macht man auch ein bisschen lieber ein, zwei oder drei davon und wenn die richtig konfiguriert sind, dann steht dieser Service auch für solche Menschen zur Verfügung, die dann normalerweise ein Problem haben.
Aber genau, aber die sagen für alle Menschen, die normalerweise ein Problem haben. Ich muss nicht für jedes Mal, wenn jemand ein Problem hat, ein neuer?
Nein, nein, nein.
Basisbit wollte noch was dazu sagen.
Also generell ist das so, dass, wie ihr schon gesagt habt, man konfiguriert das einmal, man hat den irgendwo aufgesetzt, hält ihn aktuell und dann war es das. Natürlich gibt es da wieder Ausnahmen. Wenn man jetzt irgendwo in einem Firmen-Netzwerk ist, dann kommt das oft mal vor, dass irgendwelche proprietary Firewalls noch da vorgeschaltet sind, die warum auch immer dann zum Beispiel Websocket-Verbindungen oder andere Sachen, die die Videokonferenz-Software braucht, blockieren. Da gibt es dann auch wieder so ein paar Wege, wie man da drum rumarbeiten kann, aber die haben alle jeweils vorn Nachteile. Das heißt, als Server-Operator muss man so ein bisschen sich angucken, was ist mein Klientel, und dafür kann man das Ganze ein bisschen optimieren. Aber das muss man einmal machen und dann läuft das.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich ein kleines Wort aufgreifen, das du gerade gesagt hast, nämlich du hast so ganz nonchalant in deinem Habs das gesagt und dann hält man das aktuell. Eine, weil eine sozusagen, wie soll man das sagen, so ein kleines Ärgernis oder Naserümpfen habe ich aus Administratorinnenkreisen, in denen ich nicht verkehre, aber von denen ich manchmal Dinge höre, gehört. Die so meinten, ja, das ist ja schon alles ganz schön, dass jetzt auch diese Open Source Software zur Verfügung steht, aber ich habe das Gefühl, die meisten denken, man installiert das mal und dann ist es damit getan. So, jetzt wissen wir alle, immer schöne Updates machen, etc. Aber wie schnell geht das denn? Wie viel Aufwand ist das denn, wenn man diese Dinge hat, die einfach, also natürlich gibt es immer Aufwand, wenn es Probleme gibt, aber die einfach aktuell zu halten, also dieses sich darum kümmern, ist das jede Woche ein Arbeitstag, weil gerade so viel dran gearbeitet wird, muss man da einmal im Monat gucken. Kommen diese Updates von allein, also wie aufwendig ist das? Vielleicht Steining, kannst du sagen, ihr habt irgendwie das größere Setup da am Start, wie viel Aufwand es ist?
Ich sag mal so, der Aufwand ist eigentlich nicht groß. Derzeit kommen relativ viele Releases. Das heißt, seit wir angefangen haben, für Schulen in der Corona-Krise was zu machen, sind bestimmt sechs oder sieben Updates gekommen. Und das ist jedes Mal Arbeit, einmal die Woche ist man was am Machen. Da wollte ich gerade raus. Häufig haben Schulen das Interesse, dass diese Default-Präsentation, die da zu sehen ist, so ein bisschen gebrandet ist, dass die Farbe eingestellt ist und so weiter. Da muss man sich einfach Gedanken machen, wie man das möglichst automatisiert so gestaltet, dass nachdem man das Update eingespielt hat, dass alles wieder in Ordnung ist und noch viel mehr. Man muss zwei andere Dinge tun, wenn man es jetzt im größeren Stil betreiben will. Man muss dieses Update nicht einfach blind links einspielen, sondern vorher auch mal testen auf einem eigenen Host. Und dann eben auch auf die verschiedenen Aspekte hin prüfen. Auch kann man sich vorstellen, ein Testszenario zu bauen, in dem man all die verschiedenen Zustände, in denen so ein Administrator einer Firma kommen kann, auf die Ideen, die da kommen kann und so, die muss man ja alle mal ausprobiert haben. Und dann musst du also dieses Software auch testen, auch durchaus auf Sicherheitslücken, da können wir bestimmt auch noch zusprechen, testen. Und du musst dann eben den Zustand wieder herstellen, wenn du es irgendwie customised hast, dass das nicht verloren geht und dass alle User wieder Zugriff haben und dass die Datenbank nicht verloren geht, die musst du back-upen. Da sind ja User-Daten drinnen mitunter, die registrieren sich.
Das ist nicht so wie in meinem WordPress, wo ich sage, ja, bitte mach das Update, fertig.
Wenn alles gut läuft, schon. Wenn du es gut vorbereitet hast, ist das so.
Warte, Steini, Basisbit schüttelt gerade sehr vehement mit dem Kopf.
Ja, also das kommt immer drauf an. Das, was die meisten Leute bei PQ-Button ärgert bei den Updates, ist, dass die sich nicht wirklich an die Best Practices bzw. bezüglich den Debian-Paketen halten. Das führt dazu, dass jedes Mal, wenn man ein Update installiert, werden die kompletten Pakete neu drüber gebügelt und die ganzen Dateien, die man eventuell selber geändert hat, die werden einfach überbügelt. Da sind erst mal viele von den Einstellungen weg.
Also das heißt, der installiert nicht nur die Dateien, die tatsächlich ein Update brauchen, sondern macht alles neu jedes Mal?
Ja, zumindest das Allermeiste. Aber auch da gibt es mal wieder, was typisch bei PQ-Button ist, gibt es eine Dokumentationsseite mit Best Practices oder Vorschlägen. Und dort gibt es zum Beispiel das sogenannte Apply-Update, beziehungsweise Apply-Config-Script. In diesem Apply-Config-Script, das ist üblicherweise ein Basicscript, kann man einfach seine eigenen Änderungen, die man durchgeführt hat, dann auch noch mal eintragen. Das heißt, nach dem Update wird dieses Script ausgeführt und deine Customizing-Sachen werden alle wieder angewendet. Das ist ein Schritt, wie man das machen kann, wenn man nur ein sehr kleines Setup betreibt. Geht auch relativ schnell und dann läuft das auch. Dann ist ein Update, wenn man Glück hat, in einer Viertelstunde gemacht. Allerdings muss man wissen, ob man Dokumentation gelesen hat, was ziemlich viel Dokumentation ist. Die Alternative, das was vor allem die größeren Provider eben, wie zum Beispiel bei Zenf Call oder seit kurzem jetzt auch Cyber4Ado so machen, ist, dass man Ansible-Skripte verwendet und damit dann einfach...
Was sind das?
Das ist so ein bisschen Automatisierung von Serverbereitstellung und Konfiguration, Installation und so weiter.
Also man überlegt sich vorher, wie es hinterher aussehen soll und programmiert das quasi. Ja, so in die Richtung.
Es ist ein bisschen so, weißt du, du lockst dich ja auf so einen entfernten Server ein und dann machst du da so Dinge, ja? Dann machst du ein Update, install dies, du installierst Sachen, du konfigurierst Sachen. Und so eine Ansible-Rolle ist im Prinzip diesen Vorgang automatisiert, sodass der dann an deiner Stadt sich per SSH auf der Maschine einlockt und all diese Aufgaben nacheinander ausführt, die du normalerweise von Hand machen würdest. Wenn du das einmal gemacht hast, ist es dem Skript natürlich egal, ob das das auf einer oder auf 100 Maschinen macht. Das kann dann auch gleichzeitig 20 Server installieren. Und die sind dann alle gleich. Oder du hast in diesem Skript abgelegt, welcher Server welche Präsentation hat, welche Konfiguration hat. Und dann macht er das halt für 20 Server jeweils verschieden.
Lukas, hast du auch noch Anekdoten oder Weisheiten zum Updaten?
Ja, Jitsi hat auch noch so eine kleine Besonderheit. Die sind aktuell...
Mir scheint diese Welt voller kleiner Besonderheiten.
Ja, die sind im Wandel der unterliegenden Technologie für das Loadbalancing, also dass mehrere Server gleichzeitig sich um eine Konferenz kümmern können. Und in dem Zuge haben die letztens zum Beispiel in einem großen Update jede Menge Code rausgeworfen, der von vielen Leuten produktiv eingesetzt wurde. Und generell ist da viel an den APIs und so was im Wandel. Das heißt, wenn man da Updates installiert, muss man wirklich gründlich testen, dass alle Funktionen, auf die man angewiesen sind, noch genauso funktionieren.
Also es scheint auf jeden Fall so, dass man, wenn man sozusagen eine Nummer größer betreibt, also macht man wahrscheinlich sowieso, aber dass man dieses Ding, man muss eigentlich noch mal eine weitere Instanz vorhalten, wo man diese ganzen Updates erstmal ausspielt und guckt, was dann irgendwie einem um die Ohren fliegen kann.
Unbedingt.
Dass das auf jeden Fall der Witz ist. So, und jetzt kommen wir gleich zum nächsten Punkt. Dann macht er die Updates, damit man nicht die Sicherheitslücken mitnimmt, die möglicherweise Leute entdeckt haben. Und Lukas hat da eine kleine Geschichte zu erzählen, wurde mir zugetragen.
Ja, es gab jemand anderen, der hat eine Sicherheitslücke bei Big Blue Button eingereicht, mit der konnte man beliebige Dateien von einem System lesen. Das wurde auch gefixt und das ging irgendwie groß durchs Netz. Und irgendwie alle haben dieses Update installiert und danach hat sich irgendwie niemand mehr drum gekümmert. Ich habe mich auch nicht mehr drum gekümmert. Bis ich dann irgendwann noch mal diesen Link zugeschickt bekommen habe und mir dann mal den Patch dazu durchgelesen habe und festgestellt habe, ja, aber der löst doch gar nicht das eigentliche Problem. Dann habe ich angefangen, mir das alles noch ein bisschen genauer anzugucken und habe festgestellt, das Problem ist tatsächlich nicht gelöst. Es gab eine zweite Sicherheitsankündigung, dass das Problem jetzt wirklich gelöst sei. Und kurz darauf habe ich dann noch einen Weg gefunden, mit dem man billige Dateien schreiben konnte. Und naja, das hat irgendwie dazu geführt, dass die bei BigBlueButton irgendwie panisch den kompletten Filehandling-Code irgendwie einmal umgeschrieben haben. Und naja, das war dann halt irgendwie so einmal die Woche mindestens ein Update.
Du warst das.
Aber ich muss nur kurz fragen, also beliebige Dateien lesen und schreiben. Das ist ja bei öffentlichen Videokonferenzen jetzt erst mal nicht so wild, aber jetzt muss ich mal fragen, wer kann denn diese Dateien lesen oder konnte diese Dateien lesen und schreiben? Teilnehmer dieser Videokonferenz oder jeder, der wusste, wo unter welcher Adresse der Server zu erreichen ist?
Jep, jeder, der wusste, wo dieser Server zu erreichen ist. Und das eine Datei, die man zum Beispiel auslesen kann, ist die, in der der API-Key von BigBlueButton drin steht. Und wenn man den hat, kann man sich auch ganz einfach zum Moderator machen, kann Aufzeichnungen runterladen, löschen, alles Mögliche trennen.
Das klingt aber gar nicht gut.
Genau, deshalb wurde das auch schnell gefixt.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen zu sagen. Weil Software ist nahezu beliebig komplex und Fehler können passieren. Natürlich ist es schön, wenn es gar nicht passiert, aber die Realität ist halt so, es passieren solche Fehler. Die Qualität eines Unternehmens oder einer Software macht man an zwei Dingen fest. Die eine Frage ist, ist der Code so fürchterlich, dass der voll dieser Dinge ist? Also wahrscheinlich. Und wie schnell, wie gut und wie Transparenz haben die Leute, die den Code maintainen, die sich darum kümmern, hauptsächlich sind damit umgegangen. Was ist da euer Eindruck?
Also mein Eindruck generell war eigentlich ganz gut. Also ich habe den Projektleiter von denen angeschrieben und habe irgendwie am selben Tag, irgendwie eine Stunde später oder so, schon eine Antwort gehabt mit, oh Mist. Dann haben die sich auch direkt angeguckt und kurze Zeit später kam dann der erste Fix. Dann hatte ich den nochmal geschrieben mit dem Schreiben von Dateien. Und daraufhin haben sie sich dann halt angenommen, dass sie halt nicht nur hingehen und diese eine Lücke schließen, sondern dass sie sich den kompletten Code angucken, der da drum herum gebaut ist und das halt alles sauber neu schreiben, sodass es jetzt an jeder Stelle validiert, was eigentlich angefordert wird.
Okay, das ist dann für den konkreten Fall ganz gut. Ich würde von euch dreien aber ganz generell nochmal sozusagen eine, ich weiß, wir können das hier nicht in die Tiefe diskutieren, aber als ganz genereller Eindruck bei Jitsi und BigBooButton, wie gut, nicht im Sinne der konkreten Lösung, sondern handwerklich, es gibt jetzt sagen, wie man Code schreibt, sauber kommentiert, ist das kompliziert, also wie gut ist der Code, dieser beiden Dinge, ist das sozusagen schon okay, dafür, dass es ein Open Source Gemeinschaftsprojekt ist, oder ist es eher so, mal gucken, wie lange das brennt?
Ich sag mal so, zunächst mal ist das wesentliche Kriterium, dass man überhaupt reinschauen kann. Darum geht es ja auch bei Open Source Software. Natürlich kann man auch bei nicht Open Source Software Fehler finden und Probleme, und einbrechen und so. Es wird nur mit Open Source deutlich einfacher gemacht. Und vor allem kann man sich dann auch hinterher anschauen, was haben sie denn nun getan? Also wie ist denn jetzt das Ergebnis? Beziehungsweise man kann auch selber mithelfen daran, Probleme zu beheben, wenn man sie denn ja entdeckt hat, weil man in den Source Code schaut und so weiter. Bei Big Blue Button ist so, das besteht aus vielen Komponenten an Open Source Software, die auch eigentlich für andere Sachen erstellt wurde. Free Switch zum Beispiel ist eigentlich eher eine Telefonen-Anlagen-Software für Voice-over-IP-Telefone, die da mit drinsteckt. Und ebenso andere Komponenten. Das besteht im Prinzip aus von verschiedenen Teams programmierten Komponenten und hat dementsprechend auch unterschiedliche Softwarequalität. Aber der wesentliche Vorteil gegenüber aller, sag ich mal, Closed Source Software ist, dass man das eben kann. Dass man reinschauen kann und auch partizipieren kann, an dem Prozess das dann heile zu machen.
Aber das muss ja auch passieren. Und deswegen daher die Frage, also klar sozusagen vom politisch Ideellen ist das auf jeden Fall die bessere Lösung. Aber trotzdem die Frage, wenn man dann mal reinguckt, was guckt einem dann zurück, Basisbit?
Generell sieht man bei Big Blue Button so ein bisschen, dass das über die letzten zehn Jahre hauptsächlich von so ungefähr 15 bis 20 Entwicklern immer wieder in der Freizeit und dann teilweise später auch als Beruf weiterentwickelt wurde. Da ist jetzt so ein bisschen das Glück, dass viele von diesen Komponenten, die ja schon erwähnt wurden, zum Beispiel Corento und FreeSwitch, das sind mehr oder weniger so Standardsoftwaren, die da wiederverwendet werden. Und da kümmern sich andere Leute und andere Communities hauptsächlich drum. Allerdings muss man Software ja nicht nur einbinden, sondern man muss dann das Gesamtsystem mit Installationstools und so weiter so anpassen, dass das Ganze auch ein bisschen sinnvoll abdichtet. Und das war sehr lange Zeit bei BigBlueButton so ein bisschen ins Hinterlicht geraten, sag ich mal so, aber jetzt, wo quasi der Covid-19-Sturm war und plötzlich auf die 20 Leute so ungefähr tausende Anfragen kamen, gab es dabei natürlich auch einige Leute, die so ein bisschen geguckt haben, was wird denn da überhaupt im Kurze gemacht und wo gibt es Sicherheitsprobleme. Da gibt es auch einige Stellen, die noch immer ziemlich problematisch sind, besonders bei BigBlueButton, aber es wird zumindest daran gearbeitet und da ist mittlerweile ja auch eine ganze Community an Leuten, die da zusammenarbeiten und das ist, glaube ich, einer der Stärken von Open Source, dass man da die Möglichkeit hat, reinzugucken und sie selber beizutragen, wenn man sich damit auskennt. Und das passiert gerade.
Okay, gut. Lukas, würdest du auch noch einen Satz verlieren zur grundsätzlichen Qualität von Jitsi und BigBlueButton?
Also letztendlich muss man halt sich immer vor Augen halten, wie viel komplexer eigentlich BigBlueButton ist, weil es halt diese extrem vielen Komponenten vereint. Und meine persönliche Erfahrung war halt, ich habe bisher immer, wenn ich im Jitsi-Code irgendwas gesucht habe, das in drei Schritten gefunden. Und wenn ich in BigBlueButton irgendwas gesucht habe, dann ging das irgendwo noch in eine Datenbank rein. Dann wurde das irgendwo wieder rausgeholt. Dann ging das in eine andere Software und wieder zurück. Und das muss man alles nachvollziehen. Das heißt, wenn man sich da irgendwie zurechtfinden will, dann ist das eine gewisse Einarbeitungszeit, die man auf jeden Fall für diesen Code braucht.
Aber die Qualität ist schon zufriedenstellend.
Bis auf diese Stellen, die da so ein bisschen kaputt waren.
Nee, aber wie gesagt, die gibt es ja immer. Oder lass mich die Frage noch mal anders formulieren. Ich habe mal einen Radiobeitrag über Zoom gemacht und habe mit einem IT-Experten gesprochen, der da mal reingeguckt hat. Und er meinte so, also, die haben jetzt angeguckt, also das ist schon eine Woche her, ich weiß nicht, wie der aktuelle Stand ist, aber er meinte damals, als das alles losging, er meinte so, also ich hab da mal reingeguckt und das Ding ist einfach von der Architektur so schlimm, egal was jetzt daran machen, ich kann nicht daran glauben, dass diese Software gut wird. So, und das ist ja das eine. Und das andere ist, das ist halt Software, die ist im Prinzip sozusagen folgt dir einem okayen Gerüst, aber es gibt natürlich immer wieder Stellen, die verbesserungswürdig sind. So, das ist eigentlich die Frage, die ich glaube ich stellen wollte. Basisbit, du hebst die Hand.
Also da muss man sich so ein bisschen prinzipbedingt angucken, was kriegt man überhaupt als Endanwender? Zum Beispiel auf dem Desktop kriegt man bei Zoom einen Desktop Client, den man sich installiert.
Ich will gar nicht über Zoom reden. Ich will heute hier gar nicht über Zoom reden.
Dann reden wir über BigBlueButton.
Genau, ich wollte das sagen. Ich habe den Vergleich nur gezogen, um die Frage nochmal zu stellen, wie ist das grundsätzlich?
Also ich persönlich würde mal sagen, dass das schon okay ist BigBlueButton oder Jitsi zu verwenden. Vor allem, weil sich da in den letzten Monaten noch mal ziemlich viel getan hat und auch, weil das ganze WebRTC-Standard z.B. im Webbrowser benutzt, was dann dazu führt, dass das Ganze zumindest beim Desktopclient und auch auf dem Handy usw. gar keine Rechte hat, für auf irgendwelche Sachen von den Endgeräten zuzugreifen. Das läuft eingesperrt im Webbrowser und ansonsten ist der Client zumindest da recht unproblematisch. Die Server-Software muss man sich angucken, aber die ist an sich auch okay, würde ich persönlich einschätzen.
Okay, gut, also ich nehme mal mit, das ist im Grunde genommen ein guter Ansatz und dank Open Source kann man ein Ding, das nicht in Ordnung ist, auch arbeiten. Aber muss es auch, das heißt, wenn man nicht selber daran arbeitet, man sollte immer die Updates auch erst angucken, ob sie das kaputt machen und dann auf jeden Fall einspielen, damit Dinge wie jeder, der die Adresse vom Server kennt, kann auch Dateien auslesen und schreiben, nicht passieren können. Ich würde jetzt zu dem Punkt kommen, den wir sozusagen vorhin angekündigt haben, wo ich versprochen habe, den machen wir auf jeden Fall noch, das ist die rechtliche Seite. Und die rechtliche Seite, also ich will es jetzt nicht nur sozusagen rein juristisch machen, sondern wenn wir über Videochat reden, über Videochat für geschlossene Nutzergruppen, gerade in Schulen, da geht es an besonders Schutzbedürftige, so heißen die Heranwachster auch in juristischen Kontexten. Da gibt es bestimmte, also man muss einfach bestimmte Regelungen einhalten. Es gibt die Datenschutzgrundverordnungen, von der alle schon gehört haben. Und zumindest in Hackerkreisen will man das auch. Man will ja sozusagen gar keine Daten sammeln. Über die technische Seite wollen wir gleich noch mal sprechen, also wenn man das vielleicht doch will. Aber jetzt erstmal die, ich betreibe so eine Plattform und habe also eine Datenverantwortung gegenüber meinen Leuten, die das benutzen. Was ist mit, du hast dir das ja sozusagen anscheinend mal genauer angeguckt. Was sind denn die Herausforderungen, vor denen man da steht oder anders? Brauche ich, wenn ich so ein Ding betreibe, eine Datenschutzerklärung? Wenn ja, was muss da drinstehen?
Ja, du brauchst sie definitiv. Du brauchst eine Datenschutzerklärung, da muss verdammt viel drinstehen, weil zumindest BigBlueButton standardmäßig so ungefähr alles mitlockt, alles wegspeichert und das auch für einen recht langen Zeitraum. Die Defaults sind da ausgelegt, damit wenn irgendjemand, der keine Ahnung hat, das installiert und dann Buck Report macht, damit man aus diesem Buck Report und den Logs möglichst alles, was man braucht, herausfindet, um das Buck zu fixen. Das ist nicht auf normalen Betrieb ausgelegt mit den Defaults, zumindest nicht für in der EU. Aber mittlerweile gibt es seit zwei Monaten ein bisschen was an Dokumentationen, wo so ein bisschen Best Practices gerade für in Richtung DSGVO auch drinstehen. Dazu gehört natürlich, dass man Logging an diversen Stellen entweder ausschaltet, was die einfachste Möglichkeit ist, oder eben, damit man schon ein bisschen wichtige Informationen und Fehler mitkriegt, dass man das so anpasst, dass zumindest keine personenbezogenen Daten da drin mitgeloggt werden. Dann muss man sich auch noch angucken. BigBlueButton bietet eine Funktion, wo man dann, nachdem, wenn man eine Session erstellt, also eine neue Konferenz, dann kann das Frontend einen Parameter mitgeben, wo es sagt, die Sitzung soll aufnehmbar sein oder nicht. Wenn die aufnehmbar sein soll, dann wird allerdings die komplette Sitzung aufgenommen. Und das ist den Anwendern eventuell nicht klar, weil die UI da so ein bisschen vorgeaukelt, dass der Benutzer das Starten und Stoppen kann. Eigentlich kann der Benutzer aber nur Start und Stopp, Zeitmarken für den späteren Nachschnitt nachträglich.
Also wenn dieser Raum gesetzt ist, heißt das, es wird auf jeden Fall aufgenommen?
Korrekt. Wenn der Aufnehmen-Button oben neben dem Titel vom Raum zu sehen ist, dann weißt du, du wirst gerade aufgenommen. Auch wenn da eigentlich steht, dass du nicht aufgenommen wirst. Dazu gibt es natürlich die einfachste Möglichkeit, das abzuschalten. Die Alternative, womit man das zumindest dann auch das GVO konform betreiben kann, wenn man das denn richtig argumentiert, ist, dass man ein anderes Frontend verwendet, also nicht dieses standardmäßige Greenlight, sondern irgendwas Eigenes oder eben ein modifiziertes Frontend, wo man dann in den Einstellungen sagen kann, ja, ich möchte jetzt, dass dieser Raum aufgenommen wird oder nein, ich möchte, dass der nicht aufgenommen wird.
Und dann muss man wahrscheinlich auch jedem, jeder Nutzer innen, die da sozusagen hereinkommt, das sofort am Anfang oder eigentlich vorher noch sagen, pass mal auf, wo du bist. Das ist nicht nur in dem Videochat, sondern das wird auch aufgenommen worden.
Du musst sogar noch eigentlich, also du solltest einen Schritt weitergehen im Sinne des verantwortungsvollen Umgangs und auch alle Teilnehmerinnen darauf hinweisen, dass es natürlich ein leichtes ist für jeden, der anderen, die in der Videokonferenz sind, das bei sich aufzuzeichnen. Sei es, dass sie es mit dem Handy abfilmen oder mit einem Screen-Recording einfach wegspeichern. Und dann kann das veröffentlicht werden, selbstverständlich. Also das lässt sich einfach physisch gar nicht verhindern, dass jemand das aufzeichnen kann. Und darauf sollte man zumindest noch mal auf jeden Fall hinweisen.
Wie ist das denn eigentlich mit, also in dieser Sendung wurde da ab und zu mal darüber geredet, über die Verschlüsselung von Kommunikation. Wir wissen, dass bei Jitsi und Big Pro Button ist die Kommunikation verschlüsselt zwischen, also ist der Datenverkehr verschlüsselt, dass jemand, der zwischendurch im Internet sozusagen die Pakete beobachtet, nicht sehen kann, was da drin ist. Und ist es vielleicht sogar Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, dass also nicht mal der Server sehen kann, was da drin ist. Zumindest Letzteres stelle ich mir schwierig vor, wenn irgendwie Dinge verteilt werden sollen. Aber sagt mir, wie es ist, Lukas.
Also letztendlich sind beide nur zwischen dem Client und dem Server verschlüsselt, sodass niemand von Netzbetreiber Sicht oder irgendwer im Internet-Café, oder was auch immer, das mitlesen kann. Der Betreiber des Servers kann aber auf das Video-Signal zugreifen. Bei Jitsi gibt es mittlerweile experimentelle Features, die funktionieren aktuell leider auch nur unter Chrome. Bei denen kann man tatsächlich sogar eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung aktivieren.
Das heißt, nur die TeilnehmerInnen eines Videochats können tatsächlich die Video-Signale auch benutzen?
Genau, es muss halt den Schlüssel austauschen.
Genau, es muss auf externem Weg ein Schlüssel ausgetauscht werden. Der wird auch nicht über diese Software übertragen. Der muss wirklich über einen separaten Chat oder sonst wie in den Browser eingetippt werden.
BigBlueButton bietet genau diese Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bisher noch nicht. Was Jitsi macht, wenn Chrome genutzt wird, ist, dass die da einen Standard, bzw. etwas, was gerade im Standard-Diesierungsprozess drin ist, dass man Videos, bevor die weggeschickt werden, dass man diese einzelnen Bilder noch nachträglich als Stream verändern kann. Das ist bisher von Google vorgeschlagen, dass es irgendwann mal zum Standard wird. Aber das Ganze hatte auch erst vor zwei, drei Monaten angefangen. Und das wird noch länger dauern, bis das wirklich auch mal in allen Browsern und zum Beispiel auch in Apple-Geräten ist. Also ein Jahr ist bei so was schnell vorbei. Und allgemein ist es aber sehr schwierig, performant Video-Plattformen zu betreiben, die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen haben. Wir hatten ja eben schon diese Techniken, also das SfU oder MCU genannt und genauso auch dieser Peer-to-Peer-Ansatz. Wenn man jetzt Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen macht, dann kann der Server nicht mehr auf diese Daten zugreifen. Das heißt, einerseits kann der nicht mehr die Sachen aufnehmen. Andererseits sorgt das aber auch dafür, dass der nicht wie in diesem MCU-Ansatz alle Teilnehmervideos zu einem Video umrechnen kann.
Aber das ist doch dann letztendlich nur ein weiteres Argument dafür, dass wir in Deutschland endlich alle dicke symmetrische Glasfaseranschlüsse brauchen, oder? Das ist also schon alleine, weil man dann einfach auch Video-Chat Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln kann. Das ist doch die einzige logische Konsequenz, die man aussehen kann. Hätten wir das geklärt.
Und dann bitte auch schnelle Rechner für alle.
Und dann auch noch natürlich sozusagen. Also ich sage, ich mache gleich einen Großwurf, Grundeinkommen für alle und dazu natürlich digitale Infrastruktur für jedermann. Anders kann es gehen.
Eine Grunddatenrate.
Eine Grunddatenrate, genau.
Bedingungslose Grunddatenrate.
Sehr gut. Steini, was ich dich noch fragen würde. Die Sache mit der DSGVO ist ja auch dieses Ding, also eine Idee, die da drin steckt, die wird natürlich mal mehr oder weniger umgesetzt, ist dieses, eigentlich soll immer ganz klar sein, wer meine Daten verarbeitet. Jetzt ist ja dieses Cyberphoedio, ist also ein Verein, der sich darum kümmert, dass Schulen Infrastruktur kriegen. Was bedeutet, dass die Kinder, die wiederum Eltern haben, die gesetzliche Vertreter sind, in digitalen Infrastruktur sind, die aber gar nicht von der Schule betrieben werden, sondern von jemandem dritten, nämlich ihr. War das irgendwie kompliziert, oder gibt es da sozusagen einen juristischen Kniff, falls jetzt jemand zuhört und sagt, hey geil, ich will das für meine Schulen hier auch machen. Wie habt ihr das geklärt?
Da gibt es keinen juristischen Kniff, sondern tatsächlich eine ganz klare juristische Vorgabe. Deswegen gibt es bei Cyber4Edo auch professionelle Datenschützer und Juristen im Team, die sich genau darum kümmern. Ein Vertragswerk nennt sich dann Auftragsdatenverarbeitung. Und dann gibt es dann Berge von Papier, wo drin steht was, auf welche Art und Weise, wie, wo und von wem und warum verarbeitet wird. Das ist also tatsächlich noch viel mehr Text als das, was man als Datenschutzerklärung den User abverlangen müsste. Meistens lesen sie es nicht, deswegen müsste. Und insbesondere bei Schulen und Schulkindern haben wir uns auf einen Zettel geschrieben und das auch bei einer Schule vorab exemplarisch entwickelt, sozusagen prototypisch eine Erweiterung und Ergänzung der DSGVO, die jetzt speziell an dieser Schule und andere Schulen adaptieren, das jetzt sozusagen akzeptieren als Verschärfung der Privatsphärenregelung, nenne ich das mal für Schülerinnen und Schüler. Und in dem Kontext, ich will jetzt das böse Wort nicht nochmal sagen, aber kommt es natürlich überhaupt nicht in Frage, also überhaupt nicht, nicht im Entferntesten, dass man irgendein Stück Software auf Kinder von Schul, auf Computern von Kindern installiert, die das Mikrofon anmachen kann, die Kamera anmachen kann und auf den kompletten Computer der Kinder zugreifen, die da im Kinderzimmer stehen. Das kommt einfach sowas von nicht in Frage. Das ist der Datenschutz-Super-GAU, wenn man sowas macht. Ganz egal, ob das jetzt datenschutzkonform nach DSGVU wäre oder nicht. Das muss man doch nochmal ganz klar sagen. Und deswegen ist es auch so wichtig, dass man da nochmal das besondere Schutzbedürfnis der Kinder ganz nach vorne stellt.
Aber nochmal die Frage, ihr habt also diese Auftragsdatenverarbeitung, so heißt der Begriff eben, umgesetzt und diese Papiere, stellt ihr die auch zur Verfügung, dass man diese sagen, wenn man das jetzt selber machen will, ist das quasi Open-Source-Juristerei?
Aus Gründen dürfen wir das nicht. Ich hab noch nicht verstanden, warum nicht, aber wir helfen dabei.
Also wenn man so ein Projekt startet, kann man fragen?
Ja, wir dürfen es nicht einfach online stellen, wieder aus Gründen. Aber da wissen unsere Juristen weit mehr als ich. Da möchte ich mich auch bitte, bitte nicht drum kümmern. Ich bin der Meinung, es ist komplex.
Lukas hat sich kurz gemeldet, dann wollte Basisbit auch noch was dazu sagen.
Ja, konkret zu dem Thema Software, die bei den Kindern auf dem Computer läuft und die Webcam aktivieren kann, ist jetzt gerade vor wenigen Tagen Cisco WebEx Meetings in so eine kleine Sicherheitslücke reingelaufen, die es halt ermöglicht hat, dass der Updater der Software remote exploitbar war und jemand beliebige Software nachinstallieren konnte. Und das ist halt genau das, was an dieser Stelle auf jeden Fall vermieden werden sollte.
Das ist, sagen, WebEx ist eine weitere Software, die proprietär ist und auch verwendet und nicht ganz so weit verbreitet, zumindest in meinen Kreisen. Aber okay, also man will eigentlich sozusagen, ich finde das aber ganz interessant, weil was man hier auch mitnehmen kann, ist, dass es natürlich sozusagen schick ist, wenn man Jitsi in der Open Source verwendet. Aber man hat ja nicht immer die Wahl, wenn jetzt irgendjemand kommt und sagt, du musst jetzt aber und dein Arbeitgeber willst du vielleicht agitieren. Aber vielleicht das geht ja auch nicht immer, dass man das macht. Und es gibt ja aber viele diese Angebote oder nicht viele, aber manche haben ja die Wahl. Also willst du das im Browser machen oder installiere doch unseren tollen Client? Und von allem, was ich jetzt höre, sozusagen ist die bessere Wahl also nicht in der Komfortabilität wahrscheinlich, aber vom Sicherheitsaspekt her ist die bessere Wahl, sozusagen wir machen das im Browser, weil wenn er zu ist, ist es vorbei. Und ich hab mir nicht Software-Farm Rechner installiert, die komische Dinge im Zweifelsfall macht. Basisbit wollte sowieso noch was sagen.
Genau, jetzt antworte ich erst mal auf deine Frage. Und dann mein anderes Thema. Ja, generell ist es sicherheitstechnisch besser, wenn das Ganze im Webbrowser läuft, denn das sorgt dafür, dass das Ganze so ein bisschen Sandboxed ist. Man muss über bestimmte APIs gehen, damit man zum Beispiel Webcam-Freigabe bekommt und so weiter. Und das wird dann auch standardisiert, den Benutzer angezeigt. Wenn jetzt tatsächlich auf die Webcam zugegriffen wird, macht man den Browser zu, war es das. Allerdings gibt es jetzt mehrere Anbieter, bei denen momentan aus diversen Gründen absichtlich die Desktop-App sehr stark gepusht wird und die Webversion oft zu Problemen und so weiter führt. Das heißt, die wollen natürlich einerseits ein besseres Benutzererlebnis haben, damit argumentieren die, dass die Benutzer sich den Desktop-Client installieren soll. Andererseits kommen die damit aber auch an deutlich mehr für Werbung zum Beispiel verwendbare Daten.
Naja klar, aber wenn man die Wahl hat, kann man sich dann sozusagen dafür trinken.
Ja, unter dem Aspekt sollen wir auch nochmal an den Senat appellieren. Ich möchte nämlich gerade für sehr, sehr viele Schulen in Berlin WebEx ausrollen. Das ist eine ganz schlechte Idee. Also das ist einfach eine ganz schlechte Idee.
So, aber was, du wolltest noch was zur Aufragsdatenverarbeitung und Schulen sagen.
Genau, was ja gerade jetzt im März und April passiert ist in den Schulen war, dass die Schüler und die Lehrer irgendwie das Problem hatten, dass die alleine standen, keiner denen erzählt hat, was sie machen dürfen und wie das rechtlich ist und welche Tool zu verwenden können. Die haben dann einfach das, was sie auch privat nutzen, für die Schule verwendet. Der Klassiker war dann, ach, machen wir in WhatsApp mal einfach eine Gruppe und da schickt der Lehrer ab und zu neue Hausaufgaben rein. Das führt zu diversen Problemen. Andererseits ist damit nicht sichergestellt, wer jetzt da die Datenhoheit hat. Also die Daten werden bei WhatsApp vielleicht teilweise Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, auf den einzelnen Handys gespeichert, aber die Schule hat keine Kontrolle mehr, darüber zu gucken, was wird jetzt in diesen Schätz geschrieben, was zu Problemen führt. Andererseits hat die Schule aber auch als Nutzer da jetzt keinen Vertrag für die Nutzung mit zum Beispiel dem Betreiber WhatsApp, was in dem Fall Facebook ist, abgeschlossen. Das heißt, nach DSGVO darfst du als Schule zum Beispiel kein Produkt nutzen für den Lehrunterricht, wo du keinen Auftragsdatenverarbeitungsvertrag hast. Die komplette Nutzung von WhatsApp, Zoom usw. war, wenn das nicht von der Schule irgendwie extra bestellt wurde, dann war das quasi nicht gesetzeskonform.
Also ich verstehe den Punkt, den du machen willst, aber wir verlassen jetzt gerade ein bisschen das Gebiet dieser Sendung und da möchte ich an dieser Stelle dazusagen, das muss, also das kann passiert sein und gerade was sozusagen WhatsApp angeht, ist es wahrscheinlicher, dass es so ist als andersrum, aber gerade was Zoom angeht, ist es mittlerweile auch anders. Also ich habe zum Beispiel mal selber mit einer Professorin ein Interview gehabt, die sozusagen an der Uni auch Zoom benutzt haben und das auch für das Interview benutzt hat und meinte sie, naja, also bei uns ist das extra eingerichtet worden, wir haben einen Vertrag abgeschlossen und das geht auch. Also das ist sozusagen, das ist eine politische Argumentation und die können wir heute sozusagen hier nicht zu Ende führen, die sozusagen sehr, also sehr weit ist und das, also ja, das kann schief gelaufen sein und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es so ist, auch, aber muss nicht unbedingt.
Dann noch ein abschließender Satz dazu, du hast das Wichtige schon genannt, diese Schule hat mit so einem Vertrag abgeschlossen, dann war das zumindest so, dass die Schule da aus dem Schneide raus ist.
Genau, ich wollte es nur verhindern, dass sozusagen alle sofort in helle Panik verfallen oder noch besser oder noch schlimmer sozusagen mit Mistgabeln und Fackeln zur Schule laufen, kann auch eine gute Idee sein, aber fragt vorher, ob es nicht vielleicht doch passiert ist, das ist auch möglich. Aber natürlich, ich wollte das nur der Vollständigkeit halber sagen, natürlich ist es immer besser sozusagen, das zu ermöglichen, Infrastruktur selber zu betreiben oder Infrastruktur von jemand betreiben zu lassen, der kein US-Konzern ist, der nicht das eigene sozusagen Wohlergehen im Sinn hat. So möchte ich das mal zusammenfassen.
Ganz wichtig ist auch einfach da nicht auf den großen Haufen sich zu werfen, also das schafft ja auch Begehrlichkeiten, wenn ich einen der größten Anbieter nehme, weil wer interessiert sich dann für irgendeinen Server, der in irgendeinem Regal von einem Hosting Provider steht, der jetzt für diese eine Schule ist. Also da ist die Angriffsbreite einfach auch wesentlich geringer. Jetzt nicht nur für den Missbrauch der Daten durch den Anbieter selbst, sondern auch Angriffe, wo Daten sind, kommen Daten weg.
Also ich würde die Diskussion jetzt ungern sozusagen auf dieser Ebene weiterführen, weil da kommt man immer in Teufels Küche, weil man kann sagen, also im Prinzip hast du recht, aber andererseits, wenn es sozusagen so eine Open-Source-Software gibt, wo eine Sicherheitslücke bekannt geworden ist, dann kann ich ja relativ automatisiert verschiedene Server-Adressen und so weiter und so fort, also das hat alles Vor- und Nachteile. Ich finde es immer schwierig, sozusagen an einer Stelle zu sagen, aber das ist dann das aller aller allerbeste für alle Umstände, weil so ist es ja dann doch auch manchmal wieder nicht. Ich will jetzt sagen, also Basis bitte jetzt zu sagen, letzte Wortmeldung zu diesem Thema, dann würde ich gerne noch hinter die Technik gucken, nämlich was machen wir eigentlich damit.
Unabhängig davon, welchen Anbieter man jetzt mag oder ob man das selber hostet oder nicht, ist das wichtige für einen als Verein, als Schule oder als Unternehmen, dass man, sobald man das nicht privat nutzt, einen Auftragsverarbeitungsvertrag braucht. Hat man den nicht, ist das sehr problematisch.
Ganz ganz interessant, staatliche Schulen brauchen den zwar auch, sind aber nicht strafbewehrt, wenn sie es nicht haben. Das ist ganz seltsam, in der Rechtsprechung haben wir herausgefunden, die wären da nicht belangt, wenn sie dagegen verstoßen haben. Bei privaten Schulen ist das anders, da ist die Schulleitung tatsächlich quasi haftbar, bei staatlichen Schulen ist das nicht so.
Okay, die wilden Dinge der Juristerei. Aber verlassen wir dieses Feld und begeben uns noch mal eine letzte Runde. Und das ist ja, jetzt gibt es diesen schönen Videochat. Und dann muss man was damit machen. Wie habt ihr das denn sozusagen in eurer Arbeit? Also verstehe ich vielleicht mal bei euch an. Also obwohl ich wollte zu diesem Datenschutz noch tatsächlich fragen, gab es da von den Schulen, mit denen ihr gearbeitet habt, auch Bedenken, die ihr erstmal aus dem Weg räumen musstet? Also nicht unbedingt Datenschutz, aber generell Verwendung von dieser Software oder von solcher Software?
Also die größte Kritik, und die hängt jetzt auch ein bisschen mit der Benutzung dann zusammen, ist ja, das ist doch Open-Source-Software, das funktioniert doch bestimmt nicht. Also es ist ganz interessant, es wird dann auch zur selbsterfüllenden Prophezeiung, auf eine Art haben wir gesehen, dass die Erwartungshaltung, dass da was nicht funktioniert, so groß ist, dass die meisten dann schon gar nicht mehr Bescheid sagen, wenn was nicht funktioniert, weil sie das abkanzeln, als ist halt Open-Source-Software. Und dann, da braucht nur irgendwas nicht zu funktionieren, selbst wenn jetzt der Anwender, die Anwenderin zu doof war, die Kamera anzuknipsen, dann ist es die Open-Software-Source-Software, die schuld ist. Und lass mal lieber dieses andere Tool da nehmen von diesem Hersteller.
Okay, aber so sagen, aber das war's.
Also, meine Erfahrung, was dieses Thema angeht, das ist doch Open-Source, das funktioniert doch nicht, ist vielleicht sogar ganz gut, dass die Erwartungshaltung etwas niedriger war, weil kleine Probleme, da hat sich dann keiner mehr groß drüber beschwert. Aber wenn dann bei WebEx oder bei Zoom was schiefgegangen ist, da wurde sich breit drüber ausgeklagt und es wurden Empfehlungen ausgesprochen, dass man doch besser unsere offenen Alternativen benutzen soll. Und die Nutzer waren damit am Ende auch noch zufrieden.
Nice, sehr, sehr gut. Okay, jetzt will ich aber noch zu den Konzepten dahinter kommen. Also gerade in der Schule, also ich kann noch ein bisschen anekdotische Evidenz, war es ja so, dass man dann die digitalen Werkzeuge hatte, aber dann manchmal versucht hat, einfach dasselbe zu machen, was man sonst macht. Und das ist ja dann eher sozusagen nicht so geil. Wie ist denn der Umgang, also im Sinne von, man macht halt irgendwie eine halbe Stunde Frontalunterricht, das ist natürlich als Videokonferenz extrem langweilig. Wie ist denn oder wie schnell sind Konzepte entstanden und welche sind vielleicht besonders aufgefallen?
Ich glaube, es gibt einen riesen Unterschied zwischen Grundschule und weiterführende Schule, einfach weil das Level, inwieweit man Menschen da alleine lassen kann, einfach wahnsinnig unterschiedlich ist. Das fängt an, erste, zweite Klasse, da können die ja noch nicht mal wirklich lesen in vielen Fällen. Und da ist schon die Bedienung schwierig, da müssen Eltern daneben sitzen und erst mal erklären und so weiter. Da würde ich sagen, muss ganz viel über das Visuelle gehen. Und deswegen wird in der Grundschule auch weit mehr als doppelt so viel Video benutzt, als in den weiterführenden Schulen. Da ist es eher so, dass die Kids lieber nicht das haben wollen, dass alle sehen, dass sie da noch nachtem sitzen, morgens um neun. So, aber bei den Jüngeren ist das definitiv so. Und da steht natürlich der Spielcharakter im Vordergrund. Und es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Rangehensweisen bei Schulen. Am besten geklappt hat es da, wo die Gruppen von Anfang an verkleinert wurden, weil es über Videokonferencing wahnsinnig schwer ist, 25 oder gar 30 Kinder gleichzeitig irgendwie zu interessieren für irgendwas.
Hat sich da sozusagen so eine Daumenregel rausgestellt? Also acht Leute, zehn, zwölf, was auch immer?
Das ist so, meistens wurden die Gruppen gedrittelt. Und dann eben in, das gibt es ja bei Big Blue Button auch Breakout-Rooms verschoben. Da kann man die einfach, da kann man eine Gruppe von Leuten in einen Raum tun und sagen in einer Viertelstunde kommt ihr wieder. Und dann kommen die automatisch in einer Viertelstunde zurück oder in irgendeiner Zeit. Das hat gut funktioniert, auch da muss man natürlich dann auch noch Menschen haben, die das dann da jeweils moderieren. Das ist also sehr viel personalaufwendiger auf eine Art. Dafür wurde jetzt aber auch nicht in gleichem Maße, in der gleichen Intensität unterrichtet. Also am erfolgreichsten war es meiner Wahrnehmung nach, wenn die Gruppen verteilt wurden, verkleinert wurden. Und ansonsten hängt aber das Gesamtkonzept dran. Also einfach nur Videokonferencing löst das Problem nicht. Das fängt damit an, dass die Kinder ja wissen müssen, wann sie in welchem Raum sein sollen. Und dass die Kinder dann auch das Material brauchen, an dem sie arbeiten sollen. Weil du kommst nicht drum rum, dass die halt mit Arbeitsblättern, mit Konzepten, mit Links zu Videos, die sie anschauen sollen, mit Aufgaben, die sie machen sollen, versorgen musst, über die du dann reden willst. Und das geht nur, haben wir gelernt, wenn sich ein, zwei Personen an so einer Schule wirklich dediziert dafür verantwortlich klären, nicht, dass sich da technisch oder mit uns gemeinsam, sondern ihnen halt nicht drum zu kümmern. Die größte Aufgabe ist nicht, die Kinder zu überzeugen. Die größte Aufgabe ist, Lehrerinnen und Lehrer zu überzeugen, damit überhaupt klarzukommen. Weil die haben normalerweise die größten Berührungsängste vor dieser Technik und auch die größten Probleme, in so einen Computer reinzureden.
Ach so, das ist die eine Sache. Aber jetzt hab ich so zwischen den Zeilen verstanden, dass es also reicht eben nicht, einen Videochat aufzusetzen und zu sagen, hier, das Klassenzimmer ist jetzt virtuell. Sondern man muss halt sowas wie, also wie funktioniert eigentlich Kommunikation im Digitalen? Auf welcher Plattform werden die Aufgaben verteilt? Wie kommen wir zueinander? Also da braucht es sozusagen, also es hilft nicht, ein virtuelles Klassenzimmer zu haben, sondern man braucht auch ein Konzept fürs Digitale.
Und es dauert, ich würde sagen, eine Woche tägliche Arbeit mit den Kindern. So haben wir das wahrgenommen, aber sowohl in der Grundschule als auch weiterführend, um gemeinsam mit den Kindern erst mal zu lernen, wie funktioniert das hier? Wo drücke ich, wo mache ich was? Es geht nicht in Ordnung, wenn ich die ganze Zeit im Chat, im Private Chat irgendwas dengele. Dann müssen die LehrerInnen auch ihre Tools kennen. Die müssen wissen, wie schalte ich denn das ab? Wie kann ich denn das unterbinden? Wie kann ich jetzt hier Chat verbieten? Wie kann ich Public Notes und so weiter verbieten, damit die im Fokus bleiben? Wie kriege ich... Wie kann ich auch einschätzen, ist jetzt jemand noch da oder ist jetzt jemand aus technischen Gründen rausgeflogen oder was? Das sehen die nicht. Also ich habe das live beobachtet, klassische Keule. Ja, da wird jemand, also meine Tochter wurde gefragt, sag mal, sag doch auch mal was dazu und sie hatte keinen Bock. Dann sagt sie nichts. Und das kommt auf der anderen Seite sofort an, hm, die ist wohl rausgeflogen, naja, die Source-Software. Und ich ist die angeschritten, jetzt los, mach was. Du musst jetzt was sagen, sonst denken alle, die Software funktioniert nicht.
Aber positiv gesehen, die Kinder lernen sozusagen an Medienkompetenz auch einfach ein paar Dinge, weil einfach stillhalten, weil, naja, das ist auch gut.
Aber sie lernen auch unheimlich viel. Also das, was am meisten Spaß macht, gerade Mittelstufe, Oberstufe, dafür ist Jitsi ja auch wirklich sehr gut geeignet. Aber BigBloodBatman kann das genauso gut sich eben schnell treffen. Also es gibt etliche Schüler, wir hatten an dieser Einschule jetzt, stand heute eine Umfrage unter allen Schülerinnen und Lehrerinnen, wie denn die Akzeptanz war. Und die war bei deutlich über 80 Prozent, wurde das als sehr positiv empfunden. Was aber auch damit zusammenhängt, dass das Kollegium sich einfach irre Kopf gemacht hat. Also von, die haben morgens jeden Morgen einen Podcast produziert, um die einzusammeln. Die haben sich Konzepte überlegt, auch mit uns gemeinsam. Wie erreichen sie die Schülerinnen und Schüler? Wie liefern sie die Materialien? Wie holen sie Feedback ein? Die haben Räume eingerichtet, wo man einfach vorbeigehen konnte. Zu jedem Zeitpunkt war da jemand von den Lehrkräften und hat sich der Probleme angenommen und so weiter. Das ist einfach irre gut gelaufen. Ich kann mal auch nennen, war die ESBZ hier in Berlin, Evangelische Schule, Berlin Zentrum.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen neidisch.
Die haben das extrem gut hingekriegt. Das war jetzt nicht allein unser Verdienst, wäre zu einfach zu sagen, wir haben da Videokonferenzen gemacht. Das hat das Kollegium auch hingekriegt, mit allen Schülerinnen und Schülern gemeinsam, die ESBF, also auch eine Schule aus dem Konglomerat hat das auch gemacht. Und jetzt inzwischen viele weiteren Schulen. Man merkt, es funktioniert überall da nicht so gut, wo die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer selbst Berührungsängste haben und niemand sich dieses Themas wirklich so richtig annehmen mag, sondern das eher alle als leid empfinden. Da ist es dann schwierig.
Wie siehst du eigentlich jetzt eure Aufgabe? Ich drücke ja Daumen und bete und trage mal brav meine Maske, aber die Befürchtung, dass eine zweite Welle so oder so kommt, kann ich nicht ganz ablegen. Das ist die eine Sache. Und die andere Sache ist, ich habe mit einem Bildungsexperten mal gesprochen, als das losging, und er meinte, eigentlich ist die Hoffnung ja auch, dass dieses klassische Schulding, das irgendwie Ende 19. Jahrhundert entstanden ist, dass wir das vielleicht mal langsam ablösen und dass das durch diese Krise jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen schneller geht. Also vielleicht gibt es nicht nur noch Präsenzlernen, sondern vielleicht wird Videolernen auch mehr oder weniger zum Alltag. Dieses Cyber4EDU, was ihr da gerade macht, ist das für dich so ein Ding, du hoffst, dass das irgendwann überflüssig wird, weil sich Staat, Politik und Gesellschaft auch mal ausdenken, wie digitale Infrastruktur an Schulen aussehen kann, ohne dass das ein Verein williger Eltern macht.
Ein Träumchen, ne?
Aber ist das euer Ziel, oder sagt ihr so, ne, wir bauen das jetzt weiter aus und dann werden wir halt irgendwann zur Bildungsinfrastruktur, die dann halt zur Verfügung steht? Oder die der Staat dann halt bezahlen muss, oder wie auch immer?
Ja, also in Wirklichkeit machen wir gerade was, was eigentlich das Kultusministerium machen muss, müsste. Wir erarbeiten Konzepte, es geht ja nicht um Digitalunterricht im Sinne von Informatik oder so, sondern es geht darum, wie fühlen wir die Kinder in eine digitale Welt, die ihr Leben so viel mehr beeinträchtigt. Ich vergleiche das immer mit der Klimakatastrophe. Was wir hier gerade an Vernachlässigung dieser Themen produzieren, ist mindestens genauso episch. Auf einem ganz anderen Gebiet, aber genauso fatal für zukünftige Generationen, deren Daten jetzt sich irgendwo stapeln, die irgendwann sich um einen Job bewerben, abgelehnt werden und nicht mal der Personaler, der gegenüber sitzt, weiß, warum. Weil das hat die Maschine entschieden, aus irgendeinem Datensatz, der irgendwann mal vor zehn Jahren aufgefallen ist. Diese Kompetenz, damit umzugehen, es wird einfach in fünf, zehn Jahren oder eigentlich jetzt schon und immer zunehmend viel wichtiger, damit umgehen zu können, Alternativen zu diesen Mainstream-Daten-Kraken zu kennen und zu beherrschen. Führerschein brauchst du in zehn Jahren nicht mehr, da fahren die alle alleine. Aber du musst dich auskennen, wie du die Daten deines Unternehmens schützt, wie du Privatsphäre warst, wie du damit umgehen, wie du auch Tools bedienen kannst, die nicht Standard-normal sind.
Also ich stelle im Verlauf der Sendung fest, ich stelle konkrete Fragen und es geht immer aus ganz politischer und...
Aber du hast gefragt.
Nee, aber ich habe gefragt, ob du das weitermachen willst ganz persönlich oder ob du eigentlich insgeheim hoffst, dass es reicht, so zu sagen, okay, so macht man es eigentlich, und dann diese Aufgabe sozusagen abgibst.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass es in Kürze getan ist. In Terms of den nächsten 20 Jahren sind wir da nicht. Das wäre für mich schon kürzer. Also nein, also was ich erlebe an Schulen, auch mit den EntscheidungsträgerInnen und Verantwortlichen, das ist, wir sind so hoffnungslos am Anfang und wir sind es aber auch leid, immer nur zu sagen, das geht so nicht und so können wir das nicht machen, du bist immer, also ich für mich jetzt der Buhmann, wenn ich sage, Leute, das geht nicht und wir werden dann auch teilweise schon auch, wir werden auch beleidigend wahrgenommen, weil wir scheinbar Verhinderer sind und irgendwann hast du keine Lust mehr zu verhindern und dann fängst du halt an zu sagen, okay, jetzt beantworten wir die Frage, was wäre denn in Ordnung und dann ist halt viel Arbeit und die machen wir jetzt.
Sehr gut, vielen Dank, sag ich mal, vor allen Dingen, stellvertretend für alle Eltern, die den Genuss kommen, ihre Kinder so eine total tolle Infrastruktur am Start haben und würde das auch schon als Schlusswort gelten lassen und würde aber Lukas und Basisbit auch noch die Gelegenheit geben für ein letztes, was wir aus dem Betrieb von Videochat-Konferenz-Software gelernt haben und wie wir damit umgehen.
Man muss auf jeden Fall gucken, dass man sich nicht einfach von irgendeinem Trittbett-Fahrer einen Server hinstellen lässt, der nur sehr schlecht funktioniert, aber zwar auf dem Papier toll ist, vielleicht auch Big Group Button oder sonst was Open Source ist, sondern irgendwas, womit die Schüler und Lehrer wirklich gut klarkommen. Das muss man verwenden und das ist Arbeit und das ist Zeit. Sowas kann man nicht eben als Lehrer nebenbei, neben der Schule noch für die komplette Schule betreiben. Sondern da braucht man Leute, die sich wirklich damit auskennen und die das ein bisschen professioneller betreiben oder als Hobby betreiben.
Was du sagen, was nicht heißt, dass es nicht Lehrerinnen geben kann, die das können, aber es ist halt sozusagen falsch, die Erwartung zu haben, hey, lern das jetzt mal schnell und mach das mal eben bei. So, dann Lukas.
Ja, vielleicht einfach noch zum Abschluss kurz, was ich bei uns sehe. Wie es aussieht, einfach anfangs waren viele Veranstaltungen komplett präsent, also vor Corona-Zeiten und man musste zu den Vorlesungen hin und die Professoren haben ihr Tempo hingelegt und haben viele Studenten zurückgelassen. Jetzt gibt es für fast alles eine Aufzeichnung und man kann sich im Nachhinein den Kram noch mal angucken. Jetzt merken die Dozenten selber, dass das eine gute Idee ist. Es gibt jetzt auch einige richtig gut produzierte Vorlesungen mit ordentlich lesbaren Folien und so weiter und es geht jetzt in eine Grundkonzeption, wie man denn so Remote-Vorlesungen langfristig auch anbieten kann und dass auch alles schön einheitlich ist und nicht irgendwie jeder seinen eigenen Kram macht, der eine streamt auf Twitch, der andere auf YouTube und einer hat eine Zoom-Session, sondern dass irgendwie ein System existiert, in dem alles gesammelt wird, auch das Scheduling-Problem gelöst wird. Ja und da läuft es bei uns hoffentlich in nicht zu ferner Zukunft hinaus.
Also die Welt ist nicht ganz verloren und es gibt noch Hoffnung. Ich würde jetzt gerne noch zwei Sachen sagen wollen, die mir gerade noch eingefallen sind. Basisbit, weil du arbeitest ja mit bei Senfcall.de und das ist nicht, das ist vor allen Dingen auch deshalb spannend, weil wenn ihr jetzt die Sendung gehört habt und euch aufgefallen ist, Moment mal, es gibt diese beiden Dinge und die kann man auch benutzen, warum hat mir davon noch niemand erzählt? Ich möchte das auch mal ausprobieren. Senfcall.de ist halt eben eine Instanz von Studierenden, glaube ich, hauptsächlich, die die aufgesetzt haben, wo man einfach Big Blue Button mal benutzen kann. Also da kann man sich das mal angucken, wie diese Software ist als Videochat. Und für Jitsi gibt es sowas auch, jitsi.rocks ist so ein, ich weiß, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wer genau dahinter ist, aber das ist sowas, das wird in zumindest meinem sozialen Umfeld auch empfohlen, als wenn du mal was brauchst, das sind vertrauenswürdig Leute, die das betreiben. Das ist zumindest das, was ich in den letzten Tagen und Wochen gelernt habe. Entweder korrigiert mich jetzt bitte oder gibt noch weitere Empfehlungen ab für, wenn diese Art und Weise von Videokonferenz-Software mal als Nutzer innen ausprobieren wollt, dann tut das an folgender Stelle.
Ja, zum Beispiel auch bbb.cyber von edu.org.
Ah, ihr habt auch einen öffentlichen sozusagen.
Wir haben auch einen öffentlichen Server, der kann auch noch ein bisschen.
Es gibt ein Etherpad, wo eine ganze Liste an BigBlueButton und an Jitsi-Servern drin sind, die können wir später auch als Link zu der Aufnahme bereitstellen.
Genau, also alle Angebote, die jetzt noch mal gerannt werden, die kommen auch in die Show Notes von Chaosradio.de. Lukas, hast du auch noch eine Empfehlung?
Eigentlich nicht, ich nehme die Plattformen, die angeboten werden.
Alles klar. Cool, dann also Basisbild Lukas Steini, schönen Dank, dass ihr da wart und uns teilhaben, teil gehabt haben lassen an euren Erfahrungen und Weisheiten beim Betrieb von Videokonferenz-Software. Ich fand das ganz witzig und ich freue mich auch sehr, dass meine Erwartung so ein bisschen erfüllt wurde, dass wir drüber geredet haben, was hat man jetzt schon gelernt aus der Art und Weise und was kann man vielleicht daraus lernen für die Zukunft, für die vielleicht nähere, wo man es nochmal wirklich dringend braucht, aber vielleicht auch für die weitere, wo sowas zunehmend auch Alltag werden kann und dann nicht die persönliche Ergegnung, weil das ja auch immer irgendwie die Angst ist, nicht die persönliche Begegnung entsetzen soll, aber das menschliche Miteinander auf eine digitale Art und Weise erweitern kann. Und damit möchte ich das heutige Chaosradio 261 abschließen. Bedanke mich beim Chaosradio-Team, dass diese Sendung ganz hervorragend vorbereitet hat und die tollen Gäste herbeigesucht hat. Und mir bleibt dann nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen, auch nicht im Videochat und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.